Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was du da sehen wirst.
Ich liebe das, so muss das sein. Erstmal das Equipment reinstecken.
Es hat technische Aspekte, diese Sendung wird das Chaos Radio immer... Wir sind am letzten Mittwoch im Monat mit Chaos Computer Club Berlin im Studio. Und meiner Person Max von Malodki. Chaos Computer Club heute vertreten durch Arne und Tim. Wie so oft! Vielleicht habt ihr ja die Ankündigung im Internet gelesen, worum es heute Abend grob gehen soll. Das könnte so den ein oder anderen vielleicht verwirrt haben, oder dass da jemand gesagt hat, es geht um was? Es geht um das semantische Web. Da weiß ich ja nicht mal im Ansatz, was das sein soll. Da hör ich auf gar keinen Fall rein. In Tatsache ist aber, ich habe mich dann, nachdem ich diese Reaktion an den Tag gelegt hatte, auch kurz damit beschäftigt und dann gedacht, wow, das ist ja interessant. Es dürfen also interessante drei Stunden werden heute im Blue Moon bis 1 Uhr. Worum es beim semantischen Web geht und warum das interessant sein könnte und wohin wir uns überhaupt bewegen, das können Tim und Arne besser erklären als ich. Ich habe es bis jetzt nur einmal verstanden. Das soll reichen. Oder zweimal, also zweimal hintereinander.
Das reicht ja eigentlich schon. Natürlich haben wir diesen Titel genommen, damit das alles hochakademisch klingt und dass wir total intelligent drüber kommen. Eigentlich ist das ganz einfach. Es geht einfach um das maschinenlesbare Netz. Denn dass unser eins schon eine Menge Probleme hat, Webseiten zu lesen, das wissen wir ja alle. Aber die Computer haben es derzeit noch sehr viel schwerer. Und das ist nicht gut so. Und das muss sich alles ändern. Und der Weg dahin, den wir heute mal ein bisschen beschreiben.
Da frage ich mich natürlich als Laie, was interessiert mich, dass die Maschinen dieses blöde Web überhaupt lesen können? Es geht doch wirklich darum, dass ich es lesen kann. Also inwiefern sollte das wichtig sein, dass eine Maschine das kann?
Naja, aber du möchtest ja nur das lesen, was dich wirklich interessiert. Und wenn du dir mal selber dabei zugeschaut hast, was du dir hast durchlesen müssen, bis du endlich das hast lesen können, was dich wirklich interessiert hat, hast du dir gedacht, mein Gott, warum muss ich denn das eigentlich alles tun? Und genau darum geht es eigentlich, dass man sozusagen das Relevante geliefert bekommt und das ganze Irrelevante einfach mal da lässt, wo es hingehört, nämlich beiseite.
Was dann quasi dafür sorgen würde, dass mich das Internet nicht mehr so nervt, wie es das die vergangenen Jahre von Zeit zu Zeit getan hat.
Und dass du vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr nutzen hast davon, als es bis jetzt schon der Fall ist.
Also wenn das am Ende des Blue Moons Chaosradio heute rauskommen sollte, dann würde ich das für die Erfindung der Woche oder des Monats halten auf jeden Fall. Wir werden uns also mit diesem Thema beschäftigen. In den kommenden drei Stunden hören jetzt aber erstmal ein bisschen Musik von Gregor, der nämlich im Hintergrund seine Platten auflegt und uns heute wahrscheinlich ein hervorragendes DJ-Set im Hintergrund liefern wird. Um den Eindruck zu verstärken, dass es sich heute Abend um ein kinderleichtes Thema handelt, haben wir hier einen kleinen Chor arrangiert von jungen Damen und Herren, die dem ganzen so ein bisschen diesen Mythos nehmen, dass man es nicht verstehen könnte. Auch wenn zu dem Wort Semantik alleine im Web Erklärungen zu finden sind, die nur der Literaturwissenschaftler versteht, heißt das nicht, dass Semantik im Web genau das gleich ist. Eigentlich ist es sogar eine sehr, sehr spannende Geschichte. Und gerade eben, das war ja Tim und Arne vom Chaos Radio im Grunde, war das ja auch so eine Zusammenfassung, für die man so ein bisschen ein Beispiel braucht eigentlich noch. Also es war okay, worum geht es bei Semantik im Web, aber wenn man jetzt nicht so super drinsteckt, möchte man ja gerne irgendwas Handfestes haben, wo man sagt, ah okay, das meinen die jetzt.
Ja, da gibt es sicherlich eine Menge. Also ich hatte vor ein paar Tagen mal wieder so das klassische Problem. Ich habe was gesucht und zwar habe ich einen Fleischer gesucht. Jetzt gehe ich nicht so häufig zum Fleischer und schon gar nicht gehe ich häufig zu einem Fleischer in einem Stadtteil, wo ich mich normalerweise nicht aufhalte. Wo ich aber eben war. So, jetzt die Frage, wie kriegt man das raus? Gut, ich könnte natürlich die Auskunft anrufen. Man weiß ja, was man für Erfolg hat, wenn ich irgendwie bei der Telefonauskunft anrufe und sage, ich hätte jetzt gerne mal einen Fleischer, wo ich mir irgendwie 500 Gramm Kasseler irgendwie zusammenklingle.
Fleischer in Berlin habe ich nicht. Danke dir dann immer gerne.
Peter Fleischer oder Albert Fleischer oder Ari Fleischer.
So, also Internet. Saß ich ja gerade mal davor, wie immer, und dachte mir so, google dich mal los. Man bedient sich sozusagen der einschlägigen Suchmaschinen und dann muss man halt erst mal raten. Damit fängt es ja schon mal an, weil irgendein etabliertes Verzeichnis wäre mir jetzt so konkret auch nicht eingefallen. Sicherlich gibt es irgendwelche blöden Vereinsregister, keine Ahnung. Ja genau, da bin ich dann aber auch schnell gelandet. Also so Fleischer, Berlin, Stadtteilnahme, Return. Das ging dann schon so ein bisschen in die richtige Richtung. Dann kamen dann tatsächlich Fleischerinnungen und man mag gar nicht glauben, sie hatten eine Webseite, wo alle Fleischer aufgestellt waren, die es in Berlin gab. Das ist schon mal prima. So und dann hab ich mir irgendwie so in etwa einen rausgesucht und hatte natürlich dann später das nächste Problem. Welcher von denen ist denn jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich in meiner Nähe? So und das war natürlich etwas, was mir jetzt der Computer auch nicht sagen konnte, sondern das muss ich mir schon ein bisschen selber rauskriegen. Das ist natürlich Straßennamen und Berlin. Okay, da hatte ich Glück, da kannte ich irgendwie bayerischer Platz, wusste ich. Und man mag es gar nicht glauben, die hatten sogar eine Homepage. Wie im Internet, weiß schon, so irgendwie. Dann liegen da die Kasslager und die Frikadellen irgendwie schön im rosa Licht.
Unser Fleisch, fotoähnlich.
Genau, was sie nicht alles haben. Alles ganz toll und sie haben unglaublich viel über sich erzählt und wie sie so drauf sind und wo ihr Fleisch herkommt und dass man Vertrauen haben kann und bitte und BSE gibt es sowieso schon nicht mehr. www.wurstboutique.de Genau, eine moderne Wurstboutique. Sie hatten alles, nur sie hatten keine Öffnungszeiten. Das war offensichtlich so eine Information, die sie komplett als unwichtig erachtet haben. Also musste sie mir das halt auch noch erkämpfen. Dann muss man erst mal finden, dass man die Telefonnummern rausfindet. Und es endete dann drin, dass ich sozusagen das klassische Medium Telefon bedienen musste, um das anzurufen und zu fragen, wie lange sie ihn offen haben, weil es war so 10 nach 6. Kritische Größe, schnell noch mal was besorgen. So, okay. Das ist dann sicherlich ein luxuriöser Anspruch, den ich da auch gehabt habe, dass ich jetzt mal hier so klack, klack und die mahnen mir dann auch noch so den Fleischer of Choice und das muss natürlich auch noch das gute Neulandfleisch sein. So, aber es war halt nun mal ein Bedarf in dem Moment. Und was hat das gezeigt? Das Ganze hat also für meine Verhältnisse, also es hat vielleicht insgesamt nicht lang gedauert, aber für meine Verhältnisse hat es lange gedauert. Und es hat vor allem länger gedauert als es hätte dauern müssen, wäre diese Information einfach besser beschrieben gewesen. Hätte die Fleischerei sich sozusagen auch gleich maschinenlesbar registriert mit wir sind eine Fleischerei, wir haben die und die Produkte, wir sind da und da zu finden und vor allem wir haben von dann und dann offen. Dann hätte ich anstatt selber jetzt mit dem Webbrowser losmarschieren zu müssen, die Möglichkeit gehabt, ein Stück Software einzusetzen, die mir das vielleicht automatisch raushut. Und das ist sozusagen die Vision von dem, was hinter dem semantischen Web dahinter steht. Das semantische Web heißt eigentlich Maschinenlesbar. Heutzutage ist das Web eigentlich eher nur Menschenlesbar, aber nicht wirklich Maschinenlesbar, weil die Computer verstehen eigentlich relativ wenig. Und es muss ein unglaublicher, riesiger Aufwand getrieben werden, um überhaupt eine sinnvolle Information aus dem Web herauszubekommen. Und die einzigen, denen es bisher gelingt, ist Google.
Warum eigentlich?
Na weil das alles so verborgen ist. Guck dir doch mal den Source Code von irgendeiner Webseite an, was da so alles drin steht. Da steht dann erst mal unheimlich viel sinnloser Kram drin.
Und dazwischen drin dann wenig Sinnvolles. Google indiziert alles. Wir suchen nach dem Begriff Öffnungszeiten Berlin, Fleischerei. Und mit viel Glück finden wir dann genau diese eine Fleischerei, die jetzt auch gerade noch offen hat, wenn es denn so indiziert ist. Aber das Semantische Web geht ja darüber hinaus. Das Maschinenlesbar haben wir gesagt. Welche Maschine kann das sein, die das liest? Google selber als Maschine sucht nach einem String Öffnungszeiten. Wenn ich allerdings jetzt die Öffnungszeiten unmittelbar markiere mit Öffnungszeiten, dann erkennt Google, aha, hier ist es nicht nur diese Textstelle Öffnungszeiten, sondern es geht tatsächlich um. Ja, wie komme ich zu meinem Schnitzel? Wann hat der Fleischer noch geöffnet?
Das große Problem ist, dass einfach die Leute oder die Firmen in dem Moment einfach selber noch gar nicht begriffen haben, wie ihre Webseiten so konsumiert werden. Also das Grundlegendste und die allerwichtigsten Informationen fehlen teilweise. Ich habe schon Läden gefunden, die haben eine tolle Homepage und kaufen sie bei uns ein, aber sie haben es nicht geschafft, die Adresse mal auf der Webseite draufzuschreiben. Ich meine, wie soll man denen denn dann noch helfen? Anderes Problem ist auch, dass ich, da hatten wir vorhin ja schon diese Diskussion, in den letzten Jahren ist einfach das Web missverstanden worden als eine große Lid-Fass-Säule. Gerade dieser ganze New Economy-Hype, der hat sich doch irgendwie sehr über das Visuelle selbst erfunden. Und die ganzen Leute, die halt überhaupt gar keine Ahnung haben, waren natürlich dann diejenigen, die über die großen Etats entschieden haben. Das kennen wir alle.
Ja leider, da gibt es dann auch noch Horrorgeschichten.
Horrorgeschichten finde ich ja immer spannend.
Oh ja, erzähl mal eine Horrorgeschichte.
Na es geht darum, die Fleischerei zu finden, um einfache Inhalte. Ich will an eine Information kommen, ich möchte damit was erreichen. Wie sieht das dann aus in den Agenturen? Dort gibt es dann einen Grafikdesigner, der kreiert eine wunderbare Wurstwarenwelt, baut das Ganze dann zusammen in einem Grafikprogramm, Photoshop. Es geht weiter.
Interaktiv.
Interaktiv ist ja ja die Wurst zum Anklicken.
Spielen Sie mit unserer Wurst.
Genau, die sprechende Wurst, die einen noch durch die Webseite führt.
Richtig. Buttons in Currywurstform. Das Ganze geht dann weiter an einen HTML-Code, der kann damit gar nichts anfangen. Er versteht das Grafische nicht. Von HTML versteht er auch nur mittelmäßig viel. Was macht er? Er nimmt dieses Bild und zerlegt dieses Bild dann in einzelne Kacheln. Die kann man anklicken. Die Information, wo diese Fleischerei zu finden ist, das ist ein wunderbares Beispiel, wann sie geöffnet hat, die ist dann in irgendeinem Bild hinterlegt, die natürlich noch nicht mal eine Suchmaschine findet. Schrecklich. Und das Ganze kostet dann 10 Millionen Euro.
Das wäre natürlich eine Horrorgeschichte. Jeder hat ja sowas erlebt. Jeder ist ja schon mal im Web gesurft. Beziehungsweise jeder, der schon mal im Web gesurft ist, hat schon mal solche Geschichten erlebt, hat irgendwas gesucht, was er nicht gefunden hat, hat irgendeine Seite gefunden, wo er gedacht hat, ey, wie stulle kann man eigentlich sein? Selbst wenn man bei der Bäckerinnung ist, sollte man nicht so stulle sein, dass man seine Stullen eben scheiße präsentiert. Deswegen wäre die Frage an euch, unter 0331 77 97 110, was habt ihr schon mal gesucht und gefunden, beziehungsweise gesucht und nicht gefunden? Wollen wir uns mal auf die Frage einigen? Also das wäre so was, wo ihr vielleicht einfach mal eure Horrorgeschichte ausbreitet, was ihr im Internet echt schon mal so scheiße gefunden habt, dass es nicht besser ging, oder was für ein Griff ihr gesucht habt?
Falls ihr auch Fragen habt, wie ihr gefunden werden könntet.
Genau, 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer, damit ihr euch da auch eure Geschichte rekapitulierend ins Hinterköpfchen rufen könnt, spielen wir noch mal ein bisschen Musik vom Gregor frisch aufgelegt im Hintergrund im Chaos Radio und melden uns gleich zurück. Im Hintergrund wird schon wieder Gehäuse bei uns getippt. Ihr befindet euch live beim Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Im Hintergrund wird Gregor weiter wahnsinnig gut auflegen, wie ich finde. Und gut aufgelegt seid ihr auch bzw. ihr habt gerade erst abgehoben den Hörer noch nicht aufgelegt. Am Telefon ist nämlich der Michael aus Freiburg, ein Nicht-Berliner und Brandenburger. Von so weit her rufst du an, ja?
Ja, genau.
Was hast du denn mal im Web gesucht bzw. dann auch gefunden?
Also das ist schon ein bisschen ein Zeitchen her, aber auf jeden Fall, ich habe ein Muttertagsgedicht in Englisch für meine Mutter damals gesucht, weil ich Englisch neuer Sprache hatte. Und auf jeden Fall habe ich da mindestens anderthalb Stunden lang suchen müssen, bis ich dann mal ein gescheites Gedicht gefunden habe.
Kannst du uns jetzt mal sagen, was heißt denn Muttertagsgedicht über Halt auf Englisch?
Das heißt, also Muttertag heißt Mother's Day und Gedicht heißt dann Poem. Aber auf jeden Fall muss ich da erst mal irrelang suchen, weil sehr viele Gedichte waren einfach wahnsinnig schlecht. Und ich konnte keine Seite finden, die jetzt irgendwie so links zu mehreren Gedichten hat.
Arne und Tim vom Chaosradio auf der anderen Seite. Tim sucht ganz fleißig. Ich hatte natürlich, weil wir wussten, dass du zum Thema Muttertagsgedicht jetzt was sagen wirst, schon versucht, was zum Muttertagsgedicht zu finden. Dann meintest du Englisch, dann gehen bei Tim natürlich sofort die Augenbrauen hoch. Kacke, das hab ich natürlich nicht gefunden. Hast du jetzt in der Zeit schon was gefunden, oder?
Ja, ich hab schon was gefunden. Das hat immer viel mit Essen zu tun. Hab ich hier nicht...
Ja, das scheint sich durchaus viel zu gestalten.
Das ist natürlich relativ einfach zu finden, muss ich sagen. Was für Probleme hattest du denn? Was hast du denn speziell gesucht?
Also, bei mir war das Problem, also jetzt auch vom Inhalt vom Gedicht, dass die alle ziemlich kitschig waren.
Oh ja, das sehe ich hier allerdings auch. Und? Bist du dann fündig geworden?
Ja, ich hab dann noch eins gefunden.
Nach ziemlich langen Suchen.
Und, wie war das?
Das war dann eigentlich ganz okay.
Hast du das vorgetragen?
Ja, das hab ich vorgetragen, ja.
So live, so richtig mit selber sprechen und so?
Ja, genau.
Und, hast du es noch griffbereitet?
Das ist unten in der Küche.
Achso, das ist jetzt eingerahmt an der Wand, oder wie?
Nee, meine Mutter hat es auch noch nach dem Umzug mitgenommen und hat es dann im Küchenschrank hängen.
Okay, dann war das ja doch eine relativ erfolgreiche Suche, wenn ich das so sagen darf.
Ja, doch war erfolgreich.
Und, hast du dann noch irgendwelche speziellen Bemerkungen dazu?
Aber ist doch schon mal ein gutes Beispiel. Danke dir erstmal, Michael. Ist doch erstmal ein gutes Beispiel dafür, was man so suchen kann und dass man es vielleicht gar nicht oder dann relativ spät findet, aber woran es hängt, das ist natürlich die Frage.
Ja, aber ich habe jetzt nach dem Muttertag ein Gesuch gesucht und habe jetzt fünf aufpoppte Fenster und ich habe ein 1600 Dollar Travel Shopping, kann ich nicht lesen, weil das Fenster natürlich zu klein ist, gewonnen und ich kann nach Paris fahren und muss jetzt erstmal 30 Fenster wieder zuklicken.
Damit sind wir ja schon bei einem der großen Probleme, wenn wir uns überhaupt auf die Suche begeben.
Das ist so furchtbar. Ok, aber ich habe zumindest ein Mother's Date-Poll. Falls du das irgendwie noch brauchst, kann ich dir das geben.
Nehm ich mir direkt nach Hause. Wir wollten ja erstmal zusammenfassen, so ein bisschen bis zur Nachrichten noch, was für Haken und Ösen es da überhaupt gibt, die uns genau das bescheren, dass wir es nicht wirklich alles finden.
Ja, es ist alles so furchtbar. Also erstmal, viele Leute, gerade dieses Beispiel Kleinfirmen, das zeigt das eigentlich immer wieder, schaffen es einfach nicht, zumindest mal so weit zu denken, dass man sich in die Lage versetzt, dessen, der wirklich was sucht. Also es wird sehr viel Informationen rausgetan, von denen die Leute jetzt glauben, dass das irgendwie toll ist, oder ihre Sicht der Dinge bringt, nur die wirklich relevante Information, die steht halt selten nicht da. Also fehlende Adresse, keine Öffnungszeiten beim Laden, oder dass sie einfach nicht ausreichend dokumentieren, worum es eigentlich geht, sondern dass sie einfach irgendetwas voraussetzen. Was natürlich noch ein sehr viel größeres Problem ist, ist diese totale Verliebtheit in Interaktives und Buntes. Das ist schon so ein Trend, der sich eigentlich in den 90er Jahren, meiner Meinung nach, komplett abgenutzt hat mit diesen CD-Roms. Erinnerst du dich noch? Überall diese interaktiven CD-Roms. Alle mussten sie irgendwie produzieren, aber letzten Endes, ich kann mich an keine Einzige erinnern in meinem Leben, die mich irgendwie groß bereichert hat.
Keine AOL im Briefkasten. Täglich.
Also unglaublich viel Müll, der da erzeugt wird. Es wurde auch echt viel Geld verbrannt. Aber dringend tut es halt wenig. Das Schlimme ist, dass Leute, nachdem keiner die CD-Roms haben wollte, sind die dann alle Web-Designer geworden. Und dann haben sie halt den ganzen Klumpatsch ins Web getragen. Und Firmen wie Macromedia, die haben das dann halt irgendwie bedient. Kenner ja. Flash ist zum Beispiel so ein Ergebnis. Aber auch der frühe Einfluss der Web-Designer hat dazu geführt, dass der HTML-Standard relativ früh schon torpediert wurde durch eben so Wünsche wie, ja, jetzt möchte ich die Farbe bestimmen und so weiter. Also ein Grundproblem für das Web am Anfang war, dass eben das Web mit allen Dingen verwechselt wurde, wo Layout irgendwie eine Rolle spielt. Natürlich, man möchte natürlich, dass eine Information attraktiv da geboten wird.
Also um das nochmal so zu spezialisieren, so ein bisschen, wo Layout eine Rolle spielt heißt, es soll Ähnlichkeit haben mit zum Beispiel einer Zeitung oder mit all dem Zeug, womit ich im täglichen Leben zu tun habe. Mit meinem Buch, mit meiner Zeitung und solchen Sachen.
Und Prospekte und Zeitungen und Anzeigen. Also auch gerade diese Anzeigenwelt, die hat das natürlich sehr geprägt. Das ist natürlich auch etwas, was eine Marketingagentur, so einem Entscheider, relativ einfach kommunizieren kann. Das muss jetzt genauso sein wie deine Werbung in der Zeitung, weil dann ist es halt toll. Das ist natürlich eine Sprache, die er versteht, aber es stimmt halt nicht. Weil man sucht im Web einfach was anderes. Man sucht nämlich die Information und das ist genau das, was man eigentlich in einer Zeitung, zumindest in einer Anzeige, nicht sucht. Sondern es ist eher so ein Begleitergebnis. Die Informationen, die man da sucht, sind halt die Artikel. Und wenn man sich halt mal, nimm mal einen Spiegel als Beispiel. Den blätter ich so durch. Und der ist natürlich ganz klar layoutet. Das heißt, jeder Artikel, der da publiziert wird, den erkenne ich auch sofort als solchen. Er hat immer die gleiche Überschriftgröße, dann ist da unten dieser Block, der fasst dann den Inhalt erstmal zusammen und ist noch so ein bisschen fetter vorgehoben. Und dann eben auch klar strukturiert, Absatz, Absatz, Absatz, Absatz. Und auch die Information selber ist halt so, ich kann den Artikel auch nur zur Hälfte lesen, dann habe ich das Wesentliche schon irgendwie begriffen und ich kann mir die letzten Absätze schenken, aber umso weiter ich lese, umso mehr erfahre ich. Und das ist eben der Fehler, den viele gemacht haben, dass sie eigentlich auf die rechte Seite geguckt haben, wo die Anzeige steht und nicht auf die linke Seite, wo der Artikel steht. Weil so muss man natürlich auch mit seiner eigenen Information rausgehen. Man kann im Web mit guter Information sehr viel mehr werben, als mit irgendeinem Buntkram.
Na gut, also die Frage ist natürlich, ob es nicht für bestimmte andere Sachen, so für bestimmte Arten und Weisen von Werbung, für bestimmte Sachen, wie zum Beispiel einen Film oder so. Da kannst du natürlich einen Text darüber schreiben, was der Einhalt ist, aber ist es nicht schön, da auch ein Bild von zu haben? Oder interaktiv, geht Catherine Zeta-Jones da schon mal über einen Bildschirm?
Beides, beides, beides, auf jeden Fall beides. Es geht um den Text, um die Information, und es geht auch darum, das ansprechend, ansprechend, visuell ansprechend rüberzubringen. Um die grafische Gestaltung, die gehört ganz genauso dazu, gegen die wollen wir uns auch gar nicht wenden. Nur die grafische Gestaltung nimmt bei den meisten der Websites, die wir heute finden, über 90% überhand. Und die Information kommt viel zu kurz. Bestes Beispiel vorhin, Text in Grafiken zu packen. Die Information ist nicht lesbar. Das sieht zwar schön aus, aber es ist nicht verwendbar. Du hattest den Spiegel erwähnt. Der Spiegel hatte jahrelang gebraucht, um zu dem Layout zu kommen und auch zu der Effizienz in der grafischen Gestaltung zu kommen. Im Web oder als Zeitschrift? Als Zeitschrift. Und die haben auch sehr viel Energie investiert, um zu der grafischen Gestaltung zu kommen, die sehr schlicht und einfach ist und genau die Information rüberbringt. Und genau dieses Verständnis, das ist eine grundlegende handwerkliche Frage. Bringe ich eine Information rüber? Geht es mir um die Information oder geht es mir schlussendlich nur um die Verpackung, um das schöne Bildchen, um die eine Animation, die dann da blinkt und gerät die Information in den Hintergrund? Und diese handwerkliche Fähigkeit, dieses Grundverständnis, das fehlt, muss man sagen, vorwurfsvoll sagen, fehlt den meisten Web-Designern.
Aber wie gesagt, in dieser halben Stunde haben wir ja schon mal die ganzen Web-Designer gedisst, die sich für solche halten. Wenn man das schon nicht gewährleisten kann, dass die Zunft der Web-Designer das beherrscht, was man eigentlich erwarten möchte, kann man natürlich auch nicht vom Wurstmeister um die Ecke erwarten, dass der dann seine Homepage so hinbekommt, dass es allgemein Maßstätten gibt.
Der macht das ja nicht selber.
Das macht ja der Sohn wahrscheinlich.
Oder die Tochter oder die Freund des Tochters. Nein, es ist toll, dass die Fleischerei überhaupt eine Homepage hat. Tim ist immerhin so zu seinen 500 Gramm Kasslern gekommen. Keine Homepage der Fleischerinnung, kein Kassler an dem Abend. Das ist schon mal ein Fortschritt. Die ganze Technologie ist auch vergleichsweise neu. Überlegen wir, wie lange es die Drucktechnologie gibt, überlegen wir, wie lange es das Fernsehenradio schon gibt. Da haben sich dann natürlich auch Erfahrungen herauskristallisiert. Eine handwerkliche Technik gebildet, das haben wir im Web noch nicht. Das wird noch einige Jahre dauern. Es wird natürlich immer wieder Vorreiter geben. Es wird neue Technologien geben, auf die wollen wir dann später zu sprechen kommen. Und irgendwann finden wir dann auch auf Anhieb die Öffnungszeiten einer Fleischerei.
Das ist doch schon mal ein schöner Ausblick. Wir werden uns jetzt erstmal in die Hände von Bastian Dörner und die Nachrichten begeben und werden uns dann gleich weiter über dieses Thema unterhalten im Chaosradio.
Wenn Fritz über Satellit, dann Astra Digital Radio, Transponder 30.
Ich bin ein bisschen untergegangen, wir haben es halb 11. In der Nacht ist es wieder klar vom Wetter her. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen minus zwei und minus sieben Grad. Morgen ist es meist nur locker bewirkt und es bleibt trocken. Die Temperaturen steigen dann auf sechs bis zehn Grad. Und jetzt die Meldungen mit Bastian Boehner.
Bahnkunden müssen ab Samstag auf bundesweite Warnstreiks sich einstellen. Aus Gewerkschaftskreisen ist zu hören, die Arbeitssäule punktuell niedergelegt werden, und zwar im Nah- und im Fernverkehr. Die Tarifgespräche bei der Bahn waren heute ergebnislos vertagt worden. Die Bundesregierung will der Türkei keine weiteren Waffen zur Verfügung stellen. Sie hatte in einer entsprechenden NATO-Anfrage eine Absage. Laut einem Regierungssprecher wartet die Regierung, dass nun andere NATO-Mitglieder ihren Beitrag leisten. Russland und Deutschland halten an einer Friedenslösung für den Irak fest. Das ist das Ergebnis des Gesprächs zwischen Bundeskanzler Schröder und dem russischen Staatschef Putin. Beide Seiten sind dafür, die Inspektionen im Irak fortzusetzen. Und zum Sport in der Fußball-Champions League spielt Bayer Leverkusen immer noch auswärts gegen Newcastle United. Kurz vor dem Schluss steht es aktuell 3 zu 1 für Newcastle. Und der Verkehr auf Fritz, wir haben keine Meldungen, deswegen mal gute Fahrt.
Metallica?
Metallica!
Fritz präsentiert die Band, wo Metal nach benannt wurde. Metallica, Leih, Samstag, 7. Juni in der Wohlheide Berlin. Mehr Infos zu Metallica Live in Berlin im Stahlberg. Immer sonntags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio.
DJ-Set von Gregor im Chaosradio, das gerade so viel Speed macht, dass wir es eigentlich weiter laufen lassen würden. Aber es ist ja auch eine Talk-Sendung, das heißt wir wollen uns auch weiterhin unterhalten. Im Studio sind Arne und Tim vom Chaosradio und meine Person Max von Malotki. Und wir reden heute Abend über das, was wir uns wünschen, was das Internet irgendwann mal sein soll, nämlich das Semantische Web. So habt ihr wahrscheinlich noch nicht so in den Mund genommen, diesen Begriff, weil er eben das ist, was so die Jungs benutzen, die versuchen das Web zu revolutionieren in die Richtung, dass es irgendwann mal funktioniert. Aber es bedeutet einfach, dass Maschinen besser mit diesem Internet umgehen können, sodass ihr euch auf die Maschinen verlassen könnt, dass die einfach besser was finden. Und darüber reden wir heute Abend. Und da gibt es einige Aspekte, wenn man auch denken mag, dass es sowas ist, wo man sie eigentlich nur auf Google verlassen könnte. Es gibt durchaus Alternativen. Es gibt durchaus Alternativen, als die sich auf Google zu verlassen und für immer die Augen zu verschließen, dass es keine bessere Zukunft geben könnte, als das, was Google für mich im Internet findet.
Es gibt eine Zukunft.
Also die Frage ist ja eigentlich eher, auf Google verzichten muss ja überhaupt gar keiner. Es gibt halt Möglichkeiten, wie man sich da halt bewusst raushalten kann und die sollte man eben vermeiden. In zwei, drei Sachen hat man ja eben schon genannt. Dieses simple Beispiel mit, da schreibt dann jemand seine Adresse, bei diesem einfachen Beispiel zu bleiben, von seinem Laden will er halt in irgendeiner Schrift haben. Dann erklärt ihm der Webdesigner, naja, das ist aber im Web nicht so einfach die Schrift, aber der will dann unbedingt die Hausschrift haben. Und dann entscheiden sie sich, die Adresse dann einfach als Grafik auf die Seite zu setzen. Das Problem ist, dass das eben nicht maschinenlesbar ist, sondern da müsste man dann ja schon mit einem OCR-Programm irgendwie rankommen. Und das geht natürlich nicht. Das heißt, Google oder auch alle anderen Suchmaschinen, das ist ja, wenn ich sage Google, meine ich alle Suchmaschinen, dann hat er einfach überhaupt keine Möglichkeit, diese Informationen zu erfassen. Und genau das ist eben das Problem, was viele Webseiten haben, dass die Information, die eigentlich drin ist, irgendwie verborgen ist. Entweder sie ist gar nicht drin oder sie ist auf eine Art und Weise dargestellt, wie man sie dann eben auch gar nicht weiterverarbeiten kann.
Wie sie nicht gefunden werden kann, Suchmaschinen können sie nicht finden, finden sie die Suchmaschinen nicht und finden wir die Informationen auch nicht. Und die Information, die Webseite bleibt einsam da draußen.
Haben wir da nicht einen Anrufer zu dem Thema?
Ja, haben wir tatsächlich. Wir haben den Lukas am Telefon aus Berlin. Hallo Lukas.
Ich wollte mal sagen, ich habe eine richtig geile, lustige Webseite im Internet gefunden. Und die meinte irgendwie, also ich sage jetzt mal die Webseite www.bilol.devu. Und die meinte irgendwie, dass die eine Zeitung verteilen. An verschiedenen Schulen, aber das haben die dann irgendwie auch nicht gemacht. Also ich habe die über Google gefunden. Da habe ich einfach irgendwie mal mit einem Freund auf Quatsch Bilol eingegeben. Und dann kam das einfach. Und dann weiß ich nicht, aber dann haben die das irgendwie doch nicht angeboten. Also ich habe verschiedene Leute gefragt, weil ich kenne ja verschiedene Leute von verschiedenen Schulen und irgendwo wurde die angeboten. Und so finde ich dann halt auch dumm, dass die das dann versprechen. Und dann können die das irgendwie nicht einhalten. Aber die Seite war wirklich lustig und so.
Gibt es die Seite noch?
Ja, die Seite gibt es noch.
Was hast du da eingegeben?
Das habe ich eben nicht verstanden.
Die Seite hieß www.bilol.de.vu. Also bei Google habe ich Bilol eingegeben. Bilol.de.vu, so ist die Adresse von denen. Also die haben noch an das De.vu-Gang gehängt. Und irgendwie haben die versprochen, an verschiedenen Schulen das zu verteilen. Und dann war das irgendwie nicht. Und die hatten noch nicht richtig Informationen dazu.
Na, das ist ja im Grunde nicht der Fall, dass man nicht das gefunden hat, was man möchte, oder eine Information fehlt. Das ist ja gezielte Desinformation im Grunde. Also einfach ein blöder Fall. Aber ja, danke für deinen Beitrag, Lukas.
Ja, ok, tschüss.
Probieren wir nämlich mal den Carlo, damit er nicht wieder auflegt und sich schon wieder verabschiedet. Carlo hat nämlich das Problem, dass man ihn offensichtlich nicht so gut genug findet, oder Carlo?
Indirekt so. Also ich hab einen Präzedenzfall für euch eigentlich. Ich hab für meinen Papi eine Webseite gemacht, genau was ihr angesprochen habt. Nämlich kam der irgendwann zu mir, er ist selber Kunstprofessor und meinte, er bräuchte doch jetzt mal so eine Internetrepräsentation. Und ob ich ihm das nicht irgendwie machen könnte. Und dann hab ich, also ziemlich amateurmäßig, natürlich irgendwie was zusammengebastelt, auch mit angesprochenem Flash, also auf Flash-Bases sozusagen. Und ich hab jetzt auch ein paar Freunde, die haben so ein bisschen Ahnung auch von HTML und so. Aber daran hatte ich dann auch irgendwie keine Lust, mir da irgendwie die Zähne dann auszubanken. Also, das ist natürlich, das kann man alles einfach lernen und so. Aber ich hatte da irgendwie nicht so Bock drauf. Und dann hab ich das halt damit gemacht und so. Und ich wollte nur fragen, wie man das ist, ob man sozusagen, man baut ja sozusagen das Flash-Teil in das HTML gerüstet sozusagen ein, deine Flash-Animation oder sozusagen die Flash-Webzeit. Und ob man sozusagen im HTML gerüstet sozusagen so was wie Kennwörter oder sowas verstecken kann für eine Suchmaschine.
Ja, technisch. Ist die Seite schon im Netz?
Ja, könnt ihr euch mal angucken unter www.burkhardt.de in alles zusammen geschrieben. Und da, wie gesagt, ist es ein Kunstprofessor und ich hab ja dann auch mal so geguckt, die Webseite gesucht über eine Suchmaschine, hab mich auch da eingetragen und so und kommt natürlich irgendwo ganz arschig am Ende so nach allen Einträgen, die dann irgendwo in irgendwelchen Zeitungen mal über ihnen drin standen und sowas.
Ja, ich mein, das ist so ein bisschen, du bist ja sozusagen der Klassiker, wenn ich das mal so salopp sagen darf, weil also auf der einen Seite ist das durchaus eine inhaltorientierte Seite, aber dir ist es sozusagen gelungen, dadurch, dass du das alles in so einen Flash-Block reingetan hast, das komplett vor den Suchmaschinen zu verstecken.
Genau.
Warum ist das so? Weil Flash...
Ja, ich weiß warum es ist, aber ich will also wissen, wie ich das aussehe, dass ich jetzt HTML lernen muss, es vermeiden kann, dass ich das mit Flash trotzdem immer noch irgendwie in das HTML griff, die Informationen reinbringe.
Na ja, du kannst halt es in HTML machen. Das ist halt, worum es eben geht. Viele Leute sind der Meinung, World Wide Web wäre alles, was ein Browser anzeigen kann. Das stimmt nicht. World Wide Web ist HTML. Das ist einfach die Definition von World Wide Web. Das ist das, was im Wesentlichen durchsucht wird.
Ich verstehe auch eure Stellung zu dem Thema völlig. Ich finde es auch ebendig, wenn ich mal die Sachen sehen muss, also suchen muss, aber gut.
Du wirst nie so weit kommen in einem Ranking mit so einem Flash-Kram, wie mit einer richtigen HTML-Seite.
Ich wollte das auch gar nicht professionell machen.
Ich verstehe auch deinen Ansatz. Ich weiß, dass es ein schneller Weg ist und dass es von daher auch wünschen wird. Trotzdem hast du natürlich den Wunsch, gefunden zu werden. Es gibt verschiedene Probleme. Du hast zum Beispiel einzelne Bereiche da drin. Biografie, Ausstellungen, solche Sachen. Es ist nicht möglich, auf einzelne Informationen in der Webseite zu linken. Suchmaschinen arbeiten vor allem über Links, gar nicht so sehr nur über den Inhalt. Du kannst jetzt diese Metatext noch einfügen in diese HTML-Seite. Das wird dir vielleicht auch ein bisschen helfen. Aber es wird dir nicht sehr viel helfen, weil nichts hilft dir mehr als eine vollständig aus Informationen bestehende Seite, und hier geht es ja sozusagen im Wesentlichen um Informationen, auf die auf andere Seiten verweisen können.
Da bei der Webseite geht es eigentlich vorwiegend darum, dass es so eine Art Web Repräsentation im Internet gibt, dass man ein paar Bilder hat, die man sieht, und dass man dann irgendwo noch lesen kann, wann die nächste Ausstellung ist. Und das wäre natürlich dann auch wieder wichtig, dass man so etwas dann drin hat.
Ja, eine einfache und schöne Visitenkarte im Netz. Aber es ist auch immer eine Abwägung der Mittel. Und ich werfe gerade so einen Blick über Tims Schulter auf das Display und sehe das. Sehr vieles von dem, was du da in Flash realisiert hast. Das lässt sich auch in HTML machen.
Ja, ich habe keinen Plan von HTML.
Aber die Lärm ist einfach.
Ich habe so ein Flash-Programm, da sind dann halt die lustigen Knöpfchen. Und dann macht man das dann so hin.
Ja, aber da gibt es auch HTML-Programme, da sind auch lustige Knöpfchen drauf. Also das ist wirklich nicht die Aus-Reihe.
Dann sag ich doch mal durch, ist doch gut. Dann sag jetzt mal an alle interessierten Nutzer, diese Programme mal durch.
Self-HTML ist mit Abstand die beste deutschsprachige Anleitung.
Das hat man doch dann irgendwo auf der einen Seite, sozusagen diese eine Spalte, die einen immer korrigiert auch. Und sozusagen das, was man einschreibt, in HTML korrigiert wird und so.
Eine sehr umfangreiche Anleitung. Du kannst als Einsteiger durchaus mit dieser Anleitung die ersten Schritte machen und kommst als Profi auch immer wieder darauf zurück. Also da denke ich, können wir mal ruhigen Gewissens Werbung machen.
selfhtml.team1.de Was man auch noch dazu sagen muss, ich treffe auch häufig auf Leute, die der Meinung sind, oh Gott, HTML und jetzt muss ich anfangen zu programmieren. Ich kenne fast überhaupt nichts Einfacheres als HTML im gesamten Computerbereich. Es ist so einfach, ich finde es sehr viel komplizierter, mit Flash zu arbeiten, ehrlich zu sein, als das irgendwie mit HTML zu erlernen. Weil man lernt halt auch sehr viel dabei.
Das stimmt schon, wenn ihr euch noch eine andere Website handgucken wollt...
Es gibt natürlich auch Programme, die dir sozusagen vieles der Handarbeit abnehmen. Man ist ja nicht gezwungen, wenn man jetzt eine Website macht, alles komplett von Grund auf selber tippen zu müssen.
Aber für so eine Website, die habe ich mit anderen Leuten gemacht. Da war ich dann eher so am Bildchen malen und am sagen, wo die Sachen gehen sollen, die Frames, beteiligt war, ist die Website meiner ehemaligen Schule, wo ich früher da war. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie ihr das seht, ihr müsst ja einfach gucken unter Google suchen Goethe, Wilmersdorf und Berlin. Goethe Gymnasium, Wilmersdorf Berlin.
Wir machen gleich einen Praxistest, ob wir das finden.
Wenn du konkrete Hilfe haben möchtest, es gibt auch so Programme wie zum Beispiel Go Live von Adobe, Dreamweaver von Macramedia, Microsoft hat irgendwie Frontpage, da gibt es ja diverse. Das sind halt Programme, die auch im Prinzip mit einer ähnlichen Oberfläche arbeiten, wie du das bei Flash auch hast. Nur, dass du dir nicht so einen Film zusammenstellst, sondern dass du eben einfach nur die Elemente auf die Seite setzt und dann die Links zwischen den Seiten herstellst.
Trotzdem viel zu umständlich. Das Programm zu lernen ist erheblich aufwendiger als das HTML zu lernen. Geh den direkten Weg.
Würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen, weil da kannst du ein Bild reinziehen, dann ist das irgendwie da und dann kannst du die Ausrichtung machen. Das ist alles durchaus leistbar. Das ist zumindest das, was man leisten sollte.
Ja, auch um sich das hinterher mit Müll vollzupacken.
Im eigenen Interesse, um gefunden zu werden.
Habt ihr inzwischen die andere Seite gefunden?
Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, wonach ich suchen muss, weil wenn ich nach Goethe und Gymnasium suche, da finde ich natürlich eine Menge.
Goethe, Gymnasium und dann Wilmersdorf und dann Berlin. Ja, einfach sehr egal, aber das sind so die Suchbegriffe, mit denen es klappen müsste.
Tja, auch da gibt es natürlich mehrere. Ich weiß jetzt nicht so ganz genau, ob das ist.
Da müsste irgendwas von einem Wettbewerb drin stehen. Wir haben, glaube ich, den zehnten Platz gemacht.
Na dann suche ich doch nochmal nach Wettbewerb. Dafür sind sie doch da, die Suchbegriffe. DAV-Wettbewerb um die besten Latein- und Griechisch-Webseite?
Ja, genau so ein Scheiß.
So ein Scheiß?
So ätzend. Latein und Altgriechisch, muss ich euch sagen. Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch das hat, aber es ist das Oberätzendste.
Ah, und ihr habt die beste Latein- oder Griechisch-Webseite gemacht?
Nee, leider nicht. Wir hatten, glaube ich, Platz zehn oder so. Goethe will mal drauf.
Großartig, dann werden wir uns das reinpfeifen und damit wir das verstehen, auch alle Altgriechisch lernen. Vielen Dank!
Anrapoi enepe musa, politropoin hosbalapolla.
Wunderbar, ja. Ich kann keinen Ton mehr. Also ich verstehe keinen Satz mehr davon, aber egal.
Das war HTML.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß noch bei Blue Moon. Und bekehrt schön die anderen.
Wir versuchen es. Carlo, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ja, großartig. War das wirklich nicht Griechisch, was du gerade vorgelesen hast?
Doch, das war eigentlich Griechisch.
Hast du es wirklich gehabt?
Ja, aber das ist auch der einzige Satz, den ich gemerkt habe. Ich habe mich für solche Momente beeindruckt.
Und was heißt der? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, es ist der Anfang der Odyssee von Homer.
Ah, okay.
Ob ich es richtig ausgesprochen und richtig erinnert habe, ich weiß es nicht. Aber ich könnte es nachher noch mal in HTML formulieren, wenn du möchtest.
Sehr gerne, danke.
Das wäre schön. Ja, es wird fleißig angerufen. Wir könnten im Grunde weitermachen, wenn wir wollen. Oder wollt ihr thematisch nochmal in eine andere Richtung vorher? Denn am Telefon ist der Frank aus Berlin. Hallo Frank.
Ja, hi.
Guten Abend.
Es ist jetzt nicht direkt zu dem Thema mit den Suchmaschinen, sondern mich regt eigentlich auch im Internet. Wenn ich jetzt so Firmen wie Asus oder Microsoft habe, man schickt denen eine E-Mail, man kriegt niemals eine Antwort. Also zum Beispiel bei Asus ist es so, wenn ich ein Problem mit meinem Mainboard habe, man schreibt denen eine E-Mail und die antworten noch nicht mal.
Hotline ist auch ständig nicht erreichbar.
Bei Microsoft ist es so, die haben noch diese Funktion in ihrem Betriebssystem Windows XP eingebaut. Bei Fehlern wird da automatisch so ein Report zu denen geschickt. Und da schickt man denen dann und man kriegt trotzdem keine Antwort.
Da können wir ja auch nicht helfen.
Das wollte ich nur mal so erwähnen.
Oder bei T-Online zum Beispiel, wenn man denen was schreibt, dann kriegt man so einen standardisierten Antwortbrief. Zum Beispiel in einer Fastpart.
Was war deine Frage jetzt?
Das war eigentlich nur, warum so große Firmen überhaupt so eine Funktion anbieten, wenn sie darauf überhaupt nicht antworten.
Das kann man sich natürlich fragen. Da haben wir aber auch keine gute Antwort, warum sie das nicht machen. Das ist natürlich schlechter Kundendienst.
Und zu Google zum Beispiel, zu dem Suchtdienst, würde ich mal sagen, also man muss da schon sehr genau seinen Suchbegriff abfassen, weil sonst kriegt man da jede Menge Schrott, die man angezeigt kriegt.
Bevor man das findet, was man eigentlich sucht.
Ja, das lernt man.
Das ist wie im Supermarkt so. Also wenn du nicht genau weißt, was du suchst, dann kannst du da stundenlang rummeuern. Ist da keine Frage. Aber ich finde ehrlich gesagt, die Ergebnisse von Google teilweise ziemlich bemerkenswert. Man muss halt sich immer wieder klar machen, wie Google eigentlich seine Suchergebnisse selber findet in seiner Datenbank, dann weiß man eben auch, wie man Google zu Fragen hat.
Was wir ja gerade im Grunde hatten. Dieses Ding mit dem Goethe-Gymnasium, das ist in Wilmersdorf in Berlin, kriegt man trotzdem mehrere Einträge. Und dann geht es darum, dass da mal ein Wettbewerb stattgefunden hat. Und genau mit dem Ding kriegt man eben die Seite, die man haben möchte. Also dass man selber sich überlegt, wie kann ich das wirklich eingrenzen und wo setze ich einen Minus oder einen Plus davor und solche Geschichten. Aber Frank, vielen Dank, also klar. Ja, die großen Firmen und ihr Kundendienst, das ist ja nochmal ein ans anderes Blatt. Da hat das Web ja leider nicht versagt, sondern da hat davor schon das Backend versagt, könnte man so zu sagen.
Ja, ich meine, da kann ich ja nur irgendwie mit offener Software und offenen Entwicklungsgemeinschaften kontern, weil da hat man das Problem eben nicht. Da kriegt man eher noch zu viel Antworten.
Stellt man aber leider fest, dass man die Waschmaschine nicht von einer offenen Entwicklungsgemeinschaft gekauft hat, sondern von Bosch oder so, und dann hat sich das leider schon wieder. Der Philipp ist am Telefon aus Freiburg, hallo.
Jo, hallo, ich hätte noch was kurzes zu mir hier mal suchen und nicht finden.
Ah, du warst noch vorhin schon mal in Freiburg, doch?
Ja, aus Freiburg auch, ja. Ja, also ich hatte öfters mal Probleme, wenn es um technische Sachen ging, so von meinem Rechner. Zum Beispiel war ich immer Stunden verbracht, irgendwie nach Support für eine alte Matrox-Karte zu suchen. Und ja, bin dann auch bei Google nur auf irgendwelche Links gestoßen, dann zu anderen Foren, irgendwie Support-Foren, wo dann halt echt nur Schrott drin stand oder die Einträge schon gelöscht waren. Das war mir halt super heftig, einfach durch Ewigkeit irgendwie in den Wind geschossen und dann nix gefunden.
Das ist natürlich ein sehr schwieriger Bereich, wenn man nach etwas sucht, wo es um Computer und dann auch noch um Computer-Hardware, PC-Hardware geht, wo natürlich unglaublich viel sich im Netz befindet, weil es eben einfach so nah am Thema ist. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt irgendwie über den Leuchtturm von Farros irgendetwas suchst, dann bist du im Nullkommandix da, weil sich damit natürlich der normale Computer-Anwender nicht so die ganze Zeit beschäftigt. Aber sowas wie ein Problem bei der Konfiguration der Matrusskarte, da haben bestimmt eine ganze Menge Leute eine ganze Menge Probleme.
Ja, eben aber es ist halt eben schwer, durch die Menge etwas relevanter zu machen.
Ja, dann würde ich gar nicht mal so sehr durch... Also was du vielleicht nicht probiert hast, weiß ich nicht, aber was ein Ansatz wäre, wäre bei Google kannst du zum Beispiel auch nicht nur im Web suchen, sondern auch in den Groups. Gemeint ist damit das Usenet. Das Usenet ist teilweise sehr viel fokussierter, wenn es um bestimmte Thematiken geht. Und man kann das eben durch die Auswahl der richtigen Rubrik schon sehr gut eingrenzen. Und das ist vielleicht nicht immer die Lösung, aber manchmal deutlich besser. Weil man im Web hat man das Problem, dass man eben sehr häufig, wie du schon sagtest, in diesen Support-Foren strandet, wo eigentlich auch alle schon stranden. Also man kommt eigentlich nur in die Bereiche, wo die anderen alle stranden, weil sie eben so etwas wie das Usenet nicht kennen. Und das Usenet funktioniert eigentlich sehr viel besser in der Regel als irgendwelche Web-Foren.
Vor allen Dingen deswegen, weil das Usenet irgendwie schon nach Problemen sortiert ist. Die Leute, die haben da dort sich ein Problem. Eine Webseite von einer Firma hat nie ein Problem. Eine Webseite von einer Firma hat immer die Information, von der sie denkt, dass sie das bitte dem User zukommen lassen möchte. Ich aber habe ein Problem. Und der User hat vielleicht das Problem auch schon mal gehabt. In der Regel. Also zum Beispiel, kleines Beispiel aus meiner Internetgeschichte wäre gewesen, Internetanschluss mit DSL, das Modem, was angekommen ist, ist ein Router. Also ein funktionsfähiger Router, der aber nicht als solcher genutzt werden kann, weil mir natürlich die Zugangsmöglichkeiten fehlen. So ein Ding wird ja immer übers Internet konfiguriert, in der Regel über so eine kleine IP-Adresse. Und natürlich weiß ich überhaupt nicht, unter welcher IP-Adresse der zu finden ist, geschweige denn welches Passwort dieses Ding überhaupt benutzt, weil ich habe keine funktionsfähige Anleitung dazu bekommen. Also gehe ich ins Internet und denke mir, es muss doch bei der Firma dieser Router zu finden sein, mit Anleitung. Gibt es aber nicht mehr, und da gibt es aber ein paar Leute, die dieses Problem auch schon hatten, und tatsächlich die alles rausgefunden haben, und in irgendeiner Newsgroup steht das ganze Ding, dann mit Link und so weiter, zu finden, mit dem Code wurde hinten dran geklatscht, was so das Standardpasswort ist, was vergeben wird.
War das Standort, das war schon geheim, oder?
Nee, nee, das war irgendwie, war glaube ich, was politisch war. Vorsicht. Aber da finde ich das Newsnet auch immer wunderbar, weil wirklich die Leute die gleichen Probleme haben. Es findet sich immer irgendeiner. Und da kann man auch immer total viele Worte eingeben, wie z.B. habe da und damit ein Problem, wie soll ich das eigentlich lösen? So Satzstrukturen einfach einzugeben, hilft manchmal. Wunder.
Ja, das Netz, das mich versteht.
Jo, mich hätte dann irgendwie noch was kurz. Also ich bin halt auch Studiowettung, Screening für einen auch hier in Freiburg. Ja, mache halt nebenher auch schon Aufträge und wollte ja eben mal noch dazu sagen, ich meine, das ist halt dann auch nicht so einfach immer, weil der Kunde so, der will dann halt auch irgendwie Flash haben eben. Ich meine, wenn der Kunde halt Flash haben will, kann ich ihm halt nicht erzählen, gut, du hast damit nicht so gut gefunden.
Nein, der Kunde will kein Flash haben, behaupte ich jetzt. Was will der Kunde haben? Der Kunde hat ein Produkt, der möchte das Produkt verkaufen. So ist das am meisten so eine Dienstleistung. Und er möchte diese Dienstleistung anbieten. Er möchte eine Idee übermitteln. Und wenn Flash nicht das geeignete Mittel der Wahl ist, dann musst du das Standing haben, musst sagen, hey Kunde, wir können es besser. Flash ist die eine Möglichkeit, mit der es nicht ganz so gut klappt. Wir können es besser. Wir machen das direkt in HTML, so dass das Ganze auch gefunden wird. Wir nehmen möglicherweise eine ganz andere Technik. Aber dazu musst du natürlich dann auch die gesamte Technologie beherrschen und musst das abwägen können. Und dann kannst du auch dem Kunden durchaus verklickern, kannst sagen, hey Kunde, du hast zwar Flash gehört, weil dein Kollege das hat, aber wir machen das anders.
Geil. Also der große Rat, einfach die Eier haben. Sekunde mal Kunde. Ich meine, das wird am Anfang relativ schwierig sein, oder?
Ja klar. Ich meine, das ist da schon ein Problem. Ich meine, wenn man da routinierter ist, kann man das schon wieder mal durchsetzen. Was anderes war halt auch noch, was ich halt auch immer wieder sehe, hat ja auch damit zu tun, mit der Barrierefreiheit von Webseiten eben. Weil das ist ja derzeit auch noch ein Problem, dass Text-Bowser mit vielen Webseiten einfach nichts anfangen können.
Ja, wichtiges Thema.
Ja, also irgendwie weiß ich dann ja, ob das stimmt.
Nimmst du darauf Rücksicht?
Also ich meine, ich hab die Weisheit auch nicht mit Löffeln gesessen, aber ich schau halt schon, dass ich das weitgehendstwo fertig mach. Oder halt, dass das auch für Text-Bowser lesbar ist.
Aber da kommst du natürlich mit Flash nicht sehr weit.
Nee klar, mit Flash nicht. Aber halt, wenn ich halt was in HTML mach.
Du sagst, du studierst Screendesign. Wird das auch gelehrt, dass man auf Accessibility, auf Zugreifbarkeit achten muss? Oder ist das ein reiner Flash-Kurs?
Also wir haben jetzt verschiedene Fächer, unter anderem halt auch Flash. Aber dann halt auch, ja wirklich HTML und CSF haben wir viel gemacht. Ja, und halt solche Geschichten.
Und direkt Accessibility und Usability, dass sowas mal getestet wird, wie geht ein User damit um? Und kommt er tatsächlich zu den Informationen?
Ähm, das ist schon auch ein Thema, ja.
Aber kein großes, wie es den Anschein hat.
Nee, also das ist von der geringen her nicht so groß.
Also ja, man sollte das auf jeden Fall berücksichtigen.
Könnt ihr mal, ich weiß ja nicht, ob ihr jetzt was auf der Pfanne habt, aber mich würde ja interessieren, ob es eine Webseite gibt, wo man mal sagen könnte, das ist eine große Webseite mit vielen Informationen, die es eigentlich schwierig hätte, oder so von einer großen Firma, die man kennt, auf die man gehen kann, und die haben die Webseite geil gemacht. Und das gleiche als Gegenbeispiel, die haben die Webseite absolut scheiße gemacht. Und hier gibt es das und das, was einen absolut in die Irre leitet und so.
Ja, ach da, wüsste ich schon Beispiele. Also mein klassisches Beispiel, und meiner Meinung nach eine der besten Webseiten im Web, im Sinne von sie tut das, was man von ihr verlangt, das ist einfach die Webseite von Amazon. Bei Amazon hat man von Anfang an gemerkt, die Leute wissen, was sie tun, und die Leute wissen, was sie wollen. Die haben von Anfang an auf jeglichen Schnittschlag verzichtet, die haben kein sinnloses JavaScript benutzt, die hatten keine Frames, die haben keinen Flash, und die machen das auch nicht. Darüber hinaus haben sie einfach auch noch sehr viele ganz einfache Dinge begriffen und implementiert, die alle ihre Konkurrenten nicht berücksichtigt haben. Na so was wie, dass ein Link auf ein Buch, also auf einen bestimmten Artikel, dass ich den kopieren kann, in einer Mail verschicken kann, und den klicke ich drei Monate später an, und dann kommt immer noch das gleiche Buch. Dass sich langsam um einen herum auch ein Web aufbaut. Also ein Autor hat seine eigene Homepage und sagt, ja, und ich habe irgendwie dieses Buch geschrieben, und das kannst du bei Amazon kaufen, und hier ist der Link. Während eben die Bekloppen hier gerade in Deutschland, so BOL, hier Bertelsmann, die versucht haben, mit ihren Buchclub-Strukturen ein ähnliches Versandssystem aufzumachen, gleich vom Start weg mit diesen ganzen interaktiven Klimbimmen und Frames und hast nicht gesehen, alle drei Tage andere Links. Das begreift ja hier noch nicht mal die Berliner Zeitung. Also da hat man irgendwie einen Link auf einen Artikel, und drei Tage später haben sie den unter Slash Archive irgendwo eingemottet, abgesehen davon, dass sie natürlich jetzt für das Abrufen alter Artikel auch noch Geld haben wollen, was es auch noch mal schwieriger macht. Spiegel kriegt das zum Beispiel hin. Also ich kriege zwar immer noch nicht den Artikel so, aber ich komme zumindest an die richtige Stelle, wo ich dann immer noch sagen kann, gut, ich schmeiße da jetzt mal eine 10 Cent drauf, und dann kriege ich diese Information. Auch wenn es mir das wert ist, soll es dann eben so sein. Und gerade diese permanente Links sind auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, weil das Web, deswegen heißt es ja so, lebt davon, dass es eben verflochten bleibt, dass es nicht auseinanderfällt, wie irgendwie Motten zersetzt, sondern dass es eben auf sich immer wieder verweist und diese ganze Netzstruktur aufrechterhalten wird, dadurch, dass die Links eben auch dauerhaft gelten.
Jutti, ich würde sagen, wir haben es 23 Uhr, da könnte man auch nochmal den großen Aufriss wagen und einfach mal sagen, wie diese Sendung heißt. Mit Style. Das Chaosradio, Punkt 23 Uhr. Und der Gregor ist natürlich jetzt gerade mal was essen gegangen. Von dem würden wir uns jetzt so ein bisschen Musik wünschen. Nee, macht er jetzt natürlich nicht. Insofern werden wir uns einfach noch ein bisschen mit euch unterhalten, bis der Gregor wieder zurückkommt, der hier eigentlich im Hintergrund ganz brav die ganze Zeit natürlich das DJ-Set aufgelegt hat und gerade jetzt wollen wir von ihm was haben, da geht er kurz raus. Was soll's. Kriegen wir auf jeden Fall hin. Ansonsten, worum geht's heute Abend? Das könnten wir ja nochmal für alle, die jetzt gerade erst dazugekommen sind, noch mal kurz zusammenfassen. Chaos-Radioten im Studio sind Arne und Tim, meine Person Max von Malodki. Wunderschönen guten Abend. Tim vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz so einen kleinen Snippet.
Wir reden über das Web.
Wir reden über das Web, wie es jetzt gerade ist. Wir reden über das Web, wie wir uns das eigentlich vorstellen, wie es sich gerade entwickelt, was es für tolle Sachen gerade gibt und wohin die Reise geht.
So, und jetzt hören wir ein bisschen Musik. Das DJ-Sit von Gregor im Chaos Radio, Ausgabe 79, wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche, wenn ihr Kommentare zu dieser Sendung habt oder Fragen oder Feedback und alles, was damit zu tun hat, dass ihr euch schriftlich äußern möchte, dann könnt ihr das auch tun. Eine E-Mail-Adresse gibt es dafür und zwar 79 at chaosradio.ccc.de vom Chaos Radio im Studio, also vom Chaos Computer Club, sind hier der Arne und der Tim und Max mein Name. Und es geht heute Abend um das Semantische Web, was im Grunde eine Zusammenfassung ist oder ein Wort dafür ist, was das Internet irgendwann mal sein könnte, also das World Wide Web. Und inwiefern das irgendwann qualitativ mal etwas hochwertiger werden könnte, dass wir wirklich die Informationen bekommen, die wir uns wünschen und wie das vonstatten gehen kann, nämlich mit tollen Webseiten. Ihr könnt anrufen zu dem Thema unter 03.3.1.70.97.110 und da wollen wir jetzt mal etwas spezieller werden.
Genau, wir haben ja nun gerade viel darüber geredet, warum Leute, also warum es sozusagen empfehlenswert ist, HTML zu verwenden gegenüber Flash und sagen wir mal auch bei den Standards ein bisschen frei zu sein und überhaupt expliziten Inhalts zu pflegen. Und es gibt aber auch, sagen wir mal jetzt über diese ästhetischen Gesichtspunkte und wie findet man das gleich auch noch einen anderen, wie ich finde, sehr guten Grund. Und das ist einfach der, dass man eben nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass alle die gleichen Fähigkeiten, Möglichkeiten haben, an dem Web teilzunehmen, wie man das jetzt so als Normalmensch irgendwie gewohnt ist. Ein gutes Beispiel sind Blinde, die mit Flash mal überhaupt nichts anfangen können, weil einfach visuelle Eindrücke da eben wenig zählen. Generell gibt es natürlich dann auch alle anderen Arten von Behinderungen, keine Ahnung, nur eine Arme oder so. Also dass man also einfach nicht in dem gleichen Maße teilnehmen kann, nicht eine Maus benutzen kann, wie auch immer auf die Tastatur angewiesen ist oder eben auch vielleicht nur auf eine Maus angewiesen. Also es gibt einfach verschiedene Sachen. Blinde finde ich sind immer ein ganz gutes Beispiel, weil nämlich meistens der Fehler im Schwerpunkt des Visuellen liegt bei den Webseiten und dass sozusagen der eigentliche Inhalt hinten ansteht. Blinde lesen halt Webseiten mit Breihe-Tastaturen und mit anderen Geräten. Das weiß ich mit dem Detail auch alles nicht so genau. Das würde mich aber übrigens mal interessieren, wie so die Erfahrungen von Blinden sind. Wenn ihr irgendwie blind seid und am Web teilnimmt, dann würden wir uns sehr über einen Anruf freuen und mal so ein bisschen hören, wie bei euch das eigentlich so ist mit der Teilnahme am Web. Und abgesehen davon, auch wenn man nicht unbedingt so eine offensichtliche Einschränkung hat, gibt es natürlich auch die Einschränkung der Geräte, die selten berücksichtigt wird. Heutzutage mischt sich jetzt der PDA mit dem Handy, die kleinen Palmtops, mit denen man rumläuft, die haben auch alle Netz, die hängen am Mobilfunk, die können darüber Internet machen mit GPRS und diesen neuen Standards. Und da kann man natürlich auch nicht dicke, fette, ausladende Flash-Seiten machen. Da kann man nicht davon ausgehen, dass der Bildschirm 800 x 600 Pixel groß ist oder sogar noch sehr viel größer. Oder man ist halt auch unter besonderen Umständen. Man sitzt im Auto und man hat da irgendwie so einen kleinen Bildschirm, aber man kann sich halt nicht in dem gleichen Maße auseinandersetzen. Man möchte Informationen eben auch, was sich auf Zuruf heraus sortiert bekommen. Und das sind alles diese Trends, die jetzt auch langsam für etwas Einsicht sorgen.
Wiederholen wir einfach noch mal kurz den Aufruf, weil wir die Telefonnummer gar nicht nochmal gesagt haben. 0331 77 97 110. Ihr könnt natürlich generell zu dem Thema anrufen. Wir würden uns aber wirklich sehr freuen, auch um einfach mal diese Erfahrungen, die er gemacht hat, zu teilen. Wenn jemand anruft, der blind ist und der sich mit dem Web beschäftigt, sei das über so eine breite Statue, also brei ist ja diese blinden Schrift, die man so mit den Fingern abliest. Da gibt es ja auch so kleine Geräte. Also ich habe es glaube ich in einem Film mal schon mal gesehen. Da gab es so ein kleines Gerät, was dann so Bippelchen generiert, die so von unten so hochkommen einfach. Und da hat man dann eine Zeile, die sich immer wieder ändert, sodass man das im Grunde lesen kann. Ob es das wirklich gibt, wie es das gibt, ob es schon andere Sachen gibt. Wenn ihr Blindzeit unter solche Erfahrungen gemacht habt und euren Umgang mit dem Internet schildern wollt in Sachen wie kann ich daran, Accessibility, also wie kann ich wirklich damit umgehen, dann ruft an unter 031 70 97 110. So, dann probieren wir erstmal den Mario. Mario ist nicht blind wahrscheinlich, weil Mario wartet schon eine ganze Zeit. Hat auch wahrscheinlich noch ein anderes Thema. Was ist es denn, Mario?
Hallo, ich grüße euch. Folgendes und zwar beschäftigt mich schon länger das Thema, wie kann ich den Content, den ich auf der Webseite zur Verfügung stelle, schützen, dass es halt nicht möglich ist, per Copy and Paste den vorhandenen Content wieder in eine andere Seite zu implementieren.
Kannst du ihn in ein Bild packen, dann ist er geschützt.
Ja, da habt ihr ja schon zu dem Thema auch schon geredet, dass die Schrift dann nicht mehr gut leserlich ist oder, oder, oder.
Das ist vor allem nicht für einen Computer nicht lesbar. Also dann wirst du halt von Suchmaschinen nicht gefunden. Also die Antwort kann ich dir schnell geben, ist es nicht möglich.
Ist nicht möglich.
Nein, weil wenn es gelesen werden kann von einem Computer, dann kann es auch kopiert werden, weil Lesen und Kopieren ist im Prinzip dasselbe.
Also ich leg die Information halt auf dem Rechner ab und sobald es auf dem Rechner ist, kann ich so mehr als ein Trickster auskopieren.
Ja genau, weil das lässt sich nicht verhindern. Also das ist ein Blödsinn. Das kann man nicht verhindern, dass es sozusagen Systeme verhindern.
Also in dem Bereich gibt es ja gewisse Java-Ablets, die versuchen die rechte Maustaste auszuschalten, aber sobald irgendwo das Ding auf dem Rechner...
Warum willst du denn das machen?
Warum ich es machen will? Weil es gewisse Informationen gibt, die irgendwo so viel Zeit gekostet haben für diesen Content, der zur Verfügung gestellt wird, dann im Web, also durch Recherchearbeiten, Bücher und und und, wo ich der Meinung bin, dass die Gruppe, die sich damit beschäftigt, dass das jetzt nicht jeder jetzt einfach nur dann sich rauskopieren soll.
Ja, aber dafür gibt es doch Copyright-Gesetzgebungen.
Ja, ja, klar, schon, aber jetzt sitzt da einer, der kann zum Beispiel den Text in fünf, sechs, sieben, acht anderen Worten wieder verwenden, um ihn zu sich wieder gut zu machen.
Wo ist das Problem? Ich meine, er macht das halt. Was willst du wollen? Wo stimmst du davon? Irgendwie ist doch nicht der Punkt. Du verdienst auch irgendwie durch Ruhm und Ehre und Anerkennung oder eben durch die konkrete Dienstleistung. Also entweder ihr werdet dafür bezahlt, dass ihr das tut oder ihr werdet irgendwie aufgewertet, dadurch, dass ihr es veröffentlicht. Und wenn es jetzt jemand irgendwie dupliziert, dann dupliziert es identisch so, dann lässt sich ja natürlich auch relativ einfach klarmachen, wer der eigentliche Urheber der ganzen Sache ist. Und eure Versuche, das irgendwie auf dem technischen Wege zu schützen, die werden genauso scheitern, wie die ganzen Versuche der Musikindustrie ihren Content zu schützen, der DVD-Industrie ihren Content zu schützen, das ist einfach eine Illusion, das geht nicht. Mein Tipp ist, macht euren Köpfe auf und macht euch klar, dass das Paranoia ist, was ihr da schiebt. Veröffentlicht das, wenn etwas veröffentlicht wird, dann tut das auch und veröffentlicht es wirklich. Und wenn ihr nur in der beständigen Angst lebt, das könnte jemand auch tatsächlich lesen, dann veröffentlicht das gar nicht erst. Das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Na gut, eine Angst ist ja in dem Sinne nicht. Es gehört im Endeffekt irgendwo in einem Blockade erstmal darin.
Aber ihr habt doch dann vor irgendwas Angst.
Wie bitte?
Na, vor irgendwas Angst. Wenn du irgendwas befürchtest, hast du ja Angst.
Würde ich nicht als Angst bezeichnen. Weil das ist ein Zeitfaktor, der im Endeffekt die Ausarbeitung dann zunicht gemacht hat.
Das macht aber Arbeit doch nicht zunicht.
Ihr sitzt ja auch an euren Programmen, die ihr irgendwo entwickelt, ob es nun für ein Spiel ist oder, oder, oder. Ihr sitzt ja auch eine gewisse Zeit, wo ihr euch Spaß macht, wo ihr richtig drin aufblüht und veröffentlicht ihr das. So, fünf Tage später kommt ein kleiner Typ an oder lasst es irgendjemand anders sein. Hast du nicht gesehen? Und ist der Meinung, das, was die können, kann ich ja auch. Ich nehme mir das, ziehe mir das raus, feile mir das so zurecht, wie es für mich passend ist. Ich meine, das wird auch tagtäglich provoziert. Also würde er jeden Tag irgendwo machen.
Ja, ich kann dir da eine klare Antwort zu geben. Soll er das doch bitte tun? Ja, das ist exakt genau das, was wir tun. Wir schreiben Software und dann tun wir es ins Netz und jeder soll sie nehmen und kopieren und dann soll sie mit kleinen Änderungen wieder ins Netz stellen. Was kann mir denn Besseres passieren, als dass meine Arbeit aufgenommen wird und von anderen Leuten verbessert wird? Da verliere ich doch nichts mit. Das ist doch das Beste, was mir überhaupt passieren kann. Da muss ich doch keine Angst vorhaben. Und mit Inhalten von Texten ist es im Prinzip genauso, dass es da eine gewisse Missbrauchswahrscheinlichkeit oder Möglichkeit gibt. Okay, aber die hast du so oder so, weil in dem Moment wurde deine Information mit was weiß ich für einen blöden Java-Applet in irgendeiner Form geschützt. Oder wenn du der Meinung bist, der Abdruck in der Frankfurter Eigenmeinen Zeitung wäre die einzige Möglichkeit, den Vertrieb deines Textes zu verhindern. Das ist doch Quatsch, den kann ich abschreiben und kann ich natürlich wieder machen. Also entweder er ist veröffentlicht oder nicht. Und wenn du ihn veröffentlicht, solltest du ihn auch so einfach zugänglich machen, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Weil ansonsten wird es nur zu einem führen, dass nämlich keiner deinen Text wahrnimmt. Und das hilft dir auch nicht weiter.
Außerdem kommen zumindest, das wäre der Erfolg, den du dann hast, die Jungs, die die Sachen von dir kopieren, regelmäßig auf deiner Webseite. Und dann hast du auch ein bisschen Traffic.
Um neue Informationen zu bekommen.
Mario, vielen Dank.
Gut. Hätte ja irgendwie sein können, dass ihr da irgendjemanden schonmal zu dem Thema hattet.
Hatten wir schon tausendmal. Hatten wir schon tausendmal und die Antwort ist immer die gleiche. Nicht geben kann. Habt keine Angst.
Alles klar. Die Adresse von euch, die war direkt chaosradio.de.
Chaosradio.ccc.de oder einfach www.ccc.de für die Homepage von CCC.
So und wir haben ja gefragt, ob jemand von euch möglicherweise blind ist und Erfahrungen mit Accessibility, also mit Zugangsmöglichkeiten zum Web hat und angerufen hat der René. Hallo René. Du bist blind, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Das ist richtig.
Und erzähl doch mal aus deinem Leben, wie du so mit dem Internet offensichtlich umgehst.
Ja also bei mir ist es folgendermaßen, ich nutze als Medium quasi die Breitzeile, die vorhin angesprochen wurde und auch eine Sprachausgabe. Und je nachdem, also was ich jetzt gerade im Internet mache, wie ich jetzt, also meinetwegen ob ich jetzt schneller arbeiten mache, meinetwegen E-Mails lese oder so, dann entscheide ich mich, ob ich Sprachausgabe oder Breitzeilen nutze oder beides parallel. Ich benutze einen sogenannten Screen Reader, das kommt aus dem Englischen und bedeutet Bildschirmläser. Das sind halt Programme, die Informationen von der Grafikkarte auf wie gesagt, wie gesagt, die Breitzeile oder Sprachausgabe ausgeben. Und da gibt es sowohl von einer Firma Audio Data, das Blindos, dann gibt es noch das Logo von der Firma BOM Retek AG. Das sind verschiedene Firmen, die das herstellen.
Und wie gut funktioniert das? Blindos ist ja fast lustig. Wie funktioniert das genau und wie gut funktioniert das im Endeffekt? Also wenn du da so eine Seite hast, kommt da manchmal auch der absolute Kauderwelsch bei raus?
Also ich sag mal, es kommt auf die Programmierung der Seite drauf an, da ich mich ein bisschen, will ich mal jetzt sagen, mit HTML auskenne und ja, es gibt Seiten, die sind schlecht programmiert. Es gibt aber auch Seiten, die ja eigentlich nach meinem Begabtnis sind. Beispiele, also da wüsste ich jetzt ein gutes Beispiel und zwar die Seite zdnet.de ist für meine Begriffe sehr unübersichtlich. Also überhaupt für Sehende auch.
Vielleicht könntest du ja mal, weil wir ja auch akustisch unterwegs sind, bist du in der Nähe deines Computers und könntest uns möglicherweise mal vorspielen, was dein Computer so erzählt, wenn du auf die Seite gehst über Telefon?
Das würde ich machen, aber das dauert einen Augenblick.
Das ist doch kein Problem eigentlich.
Das nimmt mich immer noch parallel, gerade im Netz.
Achso.
Ähm, Moment mal.
Na, wir können ja noch zwischendurch ein paar Fragen stellen, weil ich das hier erst mal...
Ähm, benutzt du auch... Hab ich das richtig verstanden? Dein Braierieder liest das direkt von der Grafikkarte ab, das heißt du hast deine Grafikkarte im Textmodus?
Ähm, das ist jetzt...
Kann man so sagen, also die Grafikkarte nimmt Informationen oder besser gesagt der Screenreader nimmt Informationen raus, die quasi noch vor der... Wie soll man sagen? Also bevor der eigentliche Text auf dem Bildschirm erscheint. Also wenn ich jetzt mal ein Beispiel nehme, man kann als Programmierer von Screenreadern einen Skript schreiben, wo Informationen von einer Excel-Tabelle ausgegeben werden, die der Sehende so nicht sieht. Also der Blinde sieht dann halt, in welcher Zelle oder Spalte man sich befindet. Der Sehende sieht das dann halt an der Hand von Grafiken oder an Grafiken. Also der Blinde sieht das halt am Text, mein Winkler steht dann auf der Ballseile, ich spalte 1, Zeile 2 oder so. So ich kann das hier mal demonstrieren hier. Ich habe jetzt einfach mal die Sprachausgabe hier. Ich mache die mal ein bisschen langsamer, dass man auch was versteht. So, einen Blick mal, ich kann ja noch ein bisschen was fragen, weil ich habe hier noch was einzustellen.
Gibt es auch spezielle Software, mit dem du ins Wettkeh ist oder benutzt du einen normalen Internet Explorer?
Also ich nehme den Internet Explorer. Momentan bin ich, also ich bin noch nicht up to date, wenn man so will. Ich habe ja noch den 5, 5er im Einsatz. Ich benutze auch Microsoft wie jeder andere denke ich mal.
Ich nicht, aber die meisten schon.
Ja, ist ja leider nur so. Also ich sag mal, Linox gibt es zwar auch schon Möglichkeiten für Blinde, aber die sind noch nicht so etabliert, möchte ich mal meinen.
Katja, wenn du dabei bist, also die schlechte Seite wäre ja cool, wenn wir zur Einführung, damit wir überhaupt erstmal checken, weil das für uns wahrscheinlich ganz merkwürdiges Erlebnis sein wird, jetzt dazuzuhören, erstmal eine Seite raussuchen, die gut funktioniert, wo man... Auf ritz.de werden wir sicherlich auch gesetzt. Das wird wahrscheinlich wieder ein Erlebnis, wie ich uns kenne. Wir haben momentan auch die Webseite geändert, wir haben momentan alles auf 10 Jahre fritz.de eingestellt.
Das können wir sehen, ja. Das habe ich schon mitgekriegt.
Ups, jetzt habe ich hier... Ich habe hier noch nebenbei ein Programm laufen. So, jetzt gehe ich mal auf fritz.de Können ja noch zwischendurch was fragen.
Kennst du diese Standards, diese Web-Standards, die im Prinzip ja dafür gedacht sind, euch zu unterstützen, vom World Wide Web Konsortium, also diese Accessibility-Standards?
Das ist diese Web-Accessibility...
Wie soll ich das Wort aussprechen?
Web-Accessibility.
Genau.
Aber ich bin jetzt gerade über die Frage, welche Seite das ist. Es gibt sogar die ganzen Seiten im Internet, wo man sich informieren kann über diese Standards. Und ich hab auch mal auf meiner Homepage, die momentan leider nicht besuchbar ist, weil da ein bisschen Chaos ist, habe ich auch ein paar Links dazu gemacht. Aber wenn die wieder am Netz ist, dann wäre ich mal irgendwie...
w3.org, das ist eigentlich so der Ort, wo halt die ganzen Web-Standards zusammengefasst sind. Das World Wide Web Konsortium. Was mich halt interessieren würde, ist, ob das wirklich eine konkrete Hilfe ist, wenn zum Beispiel Fotos, Bilder, auch immer mit diskriptiven, also wirklich gut beschreibenden Texten noch begleitet sind.
Das sind die sogenannten Tags, die man in HTML machen kann. Das ist eine große Hilfe. Je nachdem, welche Hilfe man einsetzt. Im Internet Explorer gibt es noch sogenannte Zusatzprogramme. Zum Beispiel von der Firma Audiodata, die nimmt den Webformator und dann gibt es noch den sogenannten Webwizard. Da wären also zwei Seiten zu nennen. Einmal die Firma, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, Audiodata, wäre zu nennen audiodata.de. Und ich gehe jetzt erstmal hier auf die Fritz-Seite. Ich kann das einmal kurz demonstrieren, wie ich mich hier auf dem Desktop bewege. Zum Beispiel Arbeitsplatz oder eigene Dateien. Kann man das so verstehen irgendwie? Ich gehe jetzt auf die Fritz-Seite. Ich mache ganz normalen Internet Explorer auf. Ich bewege mich dann mal. Ich habe jetzt die LAN-Verbindung verständlich deaktiviert. Jetzt müssen wir mir noch ein paar Fragen stellen.
Wie funktioniert das zum Beispiel im Web, wenn du eine Seite hast, die ein bisschen komplexer ist, und du willst auf der Seite was suchen, da ist irgendwo eine Suchmaske bzw. ein Feld, wo du was eingeben willst. Wie findest du dann dieses Feld? Sagt er dir dann auch das neben Suche, was er dir wahrscheinlich vorliest, das Feld ist, in das du was eingeben kannst und wie du dahin kommst?
Da kriegt es sogenannte Zusatzinformationen. Der Sehende sieht halt, dass es ein Eingabefeld ist. Und der Blinde kriegt halt die Zusatzinformationen Eingabefeld. Und genauso verhält sich das bei sonstigen anderen Schaltern, mein Bing, Auswahlschalter oder Kontrollfilter. Da kriegt halt der Blinde auch die Information, ob das aktiviert ist oder deaktiviert ist.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, bei vielen Webseiten ist es ja so, da hat man an links irgendwie so einen dicken Kasten mit irgendwie 1000 Links und rechts nochmal einen dicken Kasten. Und die eigentliche Information, die wirklich interessant ist, steht so in der Mitte. Und inwieweit hast du da Möglichkeiten, das rauszusortieren und dir wirklich nur das vorlesen zu lassen, was relevant ist?
Das halt bevorzuge ich ja Seiten mit Frames, muss ich mal so sagen. Weil Seiten, die ohne Frames gemacht sind, sind für meine Begriffe sehr, naja, da sind auch manche Seiten, wo die Links dann nochmal aufgeführt sind, obwohl man die schon besucht hat. Also, wo oben, ich sag mal, auf dem Sehen ist es sehr gut gemacht und für manche Blinde vielleicht auch, aber ich find die Seiten, die mit Frames gestaltet sind, doch besser. Weil da kann man mit bestimmten Tastenkombis gleich in den aktuellen Frame reingehen und dann sieht man gleich den aktuellen Inhalt.
Und dann hast du diesen Navigationstrahler da nicht dabei?
Ja, beispielsweise, da kann man dann gleich in den aktuellen Frame wechseln.
Verstehe.
Hast du deine LAN-Verbindung wieder aktiviert gekriegt?
Ja, Moment, ich bin jetzt gerade hier. So, ich bin schon multitaskfähig heutzutage.
Ich merk schon.
Ich hab hier in der einen Hand den Telefonhörer, in der anderen Hand mach ich hier grad Tastatur.
Ist noch so ein bisschen im Hintergrund, aber wenn du nachher mal vorliegst an einem Strang, kannst du ja ein bisschen näher an die Box halten.
Kann man das verstehen, oder?
Ein bisschen näher kannst du noch.
Also als Sprachausgabe hab ich hier die Via Voice von IBM im Einsatz. Und arbeite hier unter Windows 2000. Wo ist denn meine Netzwerkverbindung?
Das gibt's doch gar nicht.
Das hört sich doch gut an.
Neue Landverbindung.
So, aktivieren wir mal die Landverbindung. Also ich geh übers DSL ins Netz.
Selbst aktiviertes Landverbindung.
So, jetzt hat er mir gesagt, wird aktiviert das Tor jetzt hier ein bisschen.
Das ist ja großartig dazuzuhören.
So, jetzt hab ich die Seite mal aufgerufen.
Da hab ich erstmal, da sagt er mir jetzt Grafik Fritz. Fritz das Konzert, das ist so ein Bild. Das rafft er mir auch an, Grafik. Wenn ich jetzt nochmal Tapp drücke, dann kommt folgendes. Und dann geht es halt immer so weiter. Wenn ich suche jetzt mal einen Link raus. Livestream, da kommen wir in den aktuellen Real Media Stream rein. Wir gehen mal bei Audio rein.
Versuch doch mal einen Blue Moon zu finden.
Ist das auch auf der Hauptseite? Also ich bin jetzt hier noch auf der Hauptseite.
Ja, das finde ich auch gerade nicht.
Ich fände es ja spannend, lass uns einfach mal so einen Link nehmen, den wir jetzt direkt bekommen, weil wie gesagt, wir haben ja unsere Webseite umgestaltet.
Ich gehe jetzt mal ein paar Audio rein hier. Wenn es klippt, dann ist die Seite da. Das ist jetzt der Fall. Wir klicken jetzt einfach mal Video und Board. Download.
Ah, hier Play.
Wir können einfach mal so einen Livestream hier.
Wir haben Audiohilfe.
Ach, das sind alles Links hier.
Wir können ja mal zu dem Buch gehen. Mich würde mal interessieren, wenn du da was vorliest. Da ist ja dann wahrscheinlich ein längerer Text auf der Seite versteckt.
Ach so, dann müsste ich nochmal zurückgehen hier. Weil ich bin jetzt noch bei Audio hier drin.
Audio ist irgendwie über die einzelnen Jahre so.
Ich habe das jetzt schon mal reingehört. Ich gehe mal in Link zurück. Moment. So, jetzt bin ich jetzt wieder auf der Hauptseite.
Warum weiß ich nicht.
Logo Kleingift, das ist ein Bild wahrscheinlich. Ja, das ist die Frage, wo ich jetzt draufklicken muss. Ich klick mal auf das Bild drauf.
Der Beteil ist noch nicht gerechnet.
Auf was für eine Seite hab ich dich denn da geschickt, verdammt noch eins. Das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein.
Vielleicht hast du da eine andere Erlebniswelt. Mal gucken, ob wir bestehen den Test.
Fritz hat schon mal wieder kläglich versagt.
Ich find mich hier auch ehrlich gesagt selber nicht so richtig zurecht.
Chaosradio.ccc.de So, auch mal eingegeben. Dann müssen wir auch mal wissen, wo wir uns befinden.
Chaosradio aktuell, das war jetzt die Überschrift von der Seite. Das ist wieder eine Grafik. Empfang haben wir hier in Link. Wir gehen mal bei Impressum rein, oder? Wo soll ich mal reingehen?
Mich würde mal interessieren, wie du jetzt überhaupt den Inhalt der ersten Seite wahrnimmst.
Na ja, gut, dann geh ich noch mal ganz hoch.
Chaosradio aktuell.
Immer wenn er sagt Link, handelt es sich um allen Link, wo man reingehen kann. Also ich geh jetzt ganz normal die Seite runter mit dem Curver hier.
Chaosradio Ticker.
Neaktuelle Sendung. Chaosradio 79. Sendung 20. Mit 10 über 20 und 3.
Februar 20103. Davor war noch eine 079.
Das Semantische Web. Das World Wide Web hat in den letzten Jahren eine wilde Entwicklung erlebt.
Kann man was verstehen?
Von den ersten Gehversuchen bis zu überladen Multimedia-Spektakeln haben wir alles gesehen, aber hat etwas genützt. Doch obwohl die Nützlichkeit des Lebens als solchem Aufschritt ist, liegt sie noch weit hinter dem, was seine Erfinder und Weiterentwickler im Netz hatten. Wer es das Hypertext-Modell durchaus erfolge, feiert gestaltet nicht eine Suche. Im Leben darf wirklich Elefanten wie mir nach der Nadel der Sprichwörtlichen Chaosradio letztlich in Ausgabe von uns leben, sich im Leben wie es gesagt war und jetzt. Das darf dazu. Stattdessen von der Web zum nematischen Leben stehen dabei, genauso im Mittelpunkt, wie Strategien zum Endepunkt gefunden werden.
Interessante Erfahrung für uns. Wie nimmst du diese Seite wahr? Wie erfährst du das? Was bleibt jetzt? Was siehst du da?
Also ich kann bisher alles, also textmäßig gibt es hier erstmal keine Probleme. Und die Links habe ich eigentlich auch soweit. Also ich kann mir bei Gelegenheit mal einen Quelltext angucken und dann kann ich ja immer irgendwie meinen Links dazu abgeben, wenn ich da irgendwie...
Oh gerne.
Das heißt, wir haben den Test bestanden.
Ich denke schon.
Ja gerne, da geben wir uns nämlich immer viel Mühe. Zumindest glauben wir das noch, dass wir das tun. Weil darum geht es ja jetzt eigentlich auch gerade bei unserer Sendung, dass man also auch Webseiten so auszeichnet, dass man eben das Relevante macht. Und gerade, was für mich jetzt mal eine ganz andere Sichtweise war, war die Sache mit den Frames, die du gesagt hast, weil ich eigentlich immer gegen Frames, immer wetter. Warum? Im Wesentlichen, weil Frames natürlich so ein bisschen das Problem haben. Man kann eben nicht so leicht Bookmarks machen. Man kann auch nicht so leicht drauf linken, weil man ja im Prinzip dadurch, dass es eben mehrere Seiten auf einmal sind, weiß man ja gar nicht, was sozusagen die eigentliche Information ist. Also wo link ich denn jetzt hin? Weil denk ich nur auf einen einzigen von diesen Frames, dann hab ich ja alle anderen nicht.
Von Sehenden hab ich mal gehört, da ist die Übersicht einfach besser.
Ja gut, aber die Übersicht, die kann man natürlich auch ohne Frames schaffen. Das ist nichts, was jetzt Frames spezifisch haben. Es ist halt nur so, dass sich das im Prinzip in mehrere einzelne Fenster, die aneinandergeklebt sind, aufteilt. Aber das hat dann eben konkret den Nachteil, dass es mit der Grundidee des Web, nämlich, dass man eine URL für eine Information hat, damit bricht. Also man kann es nicht so gut linken. Und es gibt auch noch viel alle kleinere Probleme, die jetzt nicht so relevant sind. Also das ist schon so der Kernbereich. Aber im Prinzip müsste es auch möglich sein, auch wenn ich jetzt selber gerade ein bisschen grübel, wie wohl der beste Weg dahin ist, auf einer Webseite den eigentlich relevanten Inhalt von dem, was, sagen wir mal, jetzt Navigationsmüll ist, so zu trennen. Also dass du das jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn du auf so eine Seite kommst, von vornherein siehst, A, das hier ist alles Beiwerk und das hier ist die eigentliche Information, wie wir das jetzt zum Beispiel bei der Chaosradio Seite hatten.
so genannte Anker, aber ich weiß nicht, ob man die mitten in der Seite setzen kann, Anker oder irgendwie Textmarken.
Kann man schon, ja.
Ja, mit einer weitergehenden Semantik, mit einer Auszeichnung. Hier beginnt der Inhalt, hier haben wir einen Container, der heißt Content.
Es gibt ja manche Seiten, wo es sowas gibt, dass entweder Absätze sind oder Resten richtig dasteht. Hauptzeit oder Hauptframe, wenn da steht Hauptframe, weiß man halt, das ist jetzt der Frame, wo ich gerade bin oder so.
Genau, und das eben auch für eine Seite ohne Frames. Denkbar ist das auf jeden Fall. Für uns eine sehr wertvolle Erfahrung.
Weil du gesagt hast, du stellst das Ganze jetzt mal langsamer ein, hörst du das signifikant schneller ab, sodass wir schon gar nichts mehr damit...
Sehr schnell, also meine Kumpel sagen immer, dass du das verstehst und so.
Ja klar, weil du akustisch natürlich um einiges mehr drauf hast als wir. Wir verlassen uns da nicht so auf unsere Ohren wahrscheinlich. Du lässt dir das halt vorlesen in so einem ganz irren Tempo. Jut, René, vielen Dank für diese Erfahrung. Das war cool vor allen Dingen, dass wir das hörbar gemacht haben. Fand ich sehr geil, damit man mal einen Eindruck hat, wie du dir eine Webseite anschaust. Danke. Und wir haben es jetzt auch schon kurz nach halb. Das heißt, es ist mal wieder Zeit für Nachrichten.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Wir haben es 23.33. Das Wetter ist meist klar. Die Tiefwerte liegen zwischen minus zwei und minus sieben Grad. Am Tag ist es meist nur locker bewölkt und es bleibt trocken. Die Temperaturen steigen auf sechs bis zehn Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Boehner.
Russland und Deutschland fordern weiter eine friedliche Entwaffnung des Irak. Das ist das Ergebnis des Gesprächs zwischen Bundeskanzler Schröder und dem russischen Präsidenten Putin. Beide sind dafür, die Waffenkontrollen im Irak fortzusetzen. Die Bundesregierung will der Türkei keine weitere Militärhilfe gewähren. Sie erteilte einer entsprechenden NATO-Anfrage eine Absage. Laut einem Regierungssprecher wartet die Regierung, dass nun andere NATO-Mitglieder ihren Beitrag leisten. Bahnkunden müssen ab Samstag mit bundesweiten Warnstreiks rechnen. Heute waren die Tarifverhandlungen ohne Ergebnis vertagt worden. Die Gewerkschaft will nun mit Warnstreiksdruck auf die Geschäftsleitung der Bahn ausüben. Und zum Sport in der Fußball-Champions League verlor Bayer Leverkusen bei Newcastle United mit 1 zu 3. Leverkusen bleibt damit in der Vorrunde ohne jeden Punkt gewinnt. Oh, der Verkehr auf Fritz, wir haben keine Meldungen, also gute Fahrt.
Funk-Lebo, Mike Lehmann, ein Porträt.
10 Jahre Fritz.
Das Buch zum Lesen, Angucken und Haben. Ab sofort über allem Handeln oder Anrufen. 0331 70 97 120. 10 Jahre Fritz, das Buch. 250 Seiten Momente, Erlebnisse und Geschichten. Schicht übers Vom und Im im Radio.
Hier wird das Chaosradio auf Ritz, 20 vor 12. Das heißt, wir befinden uns kurz nach der Halbzeit in der 79. Ausgabe des Chaosradios im Studio Arne, Tim und meine Person Max von Malodki. Und wir haben euch jetzt mal ein längeres Stückchen Musik gegönnt, weil wir ja vorhin doch in Riem gesprochen haben. Aber es soll noch einen Moment um das Thema gehen. Grundsätzlich geht es heute, das kann Tim vielleicht nochmal oder Arne zusammenfassen, um das Semantische Web.
Ja, um das Semantische Web. Das Auffinden von Informationen im Web war bisher eine eher statische Sache. Mittlerweile sollen auch die Maschinen das Web lesen können, damit die Maschinen uns besser dienen können, damit wir schneller zu den Informationen kommen, die wir dann tatsächlich suchen.
Und dass das Ganze etwas problematischer sein kann, als dass wir eben bei Google was eingeben und es kommen ein paar zu viele Webseiten. Das haben wir gerade am Beispiel von René aus Eisenhützstadt bemerkt, der blind ist und der da durchaus mit zurechtkommen muss. Und deswegen haben wir noch, weil wir explizit dazu aufgerufen hatten, jetzt noch einen Anrufer zu diesem Thema.
Hallo. Hallöchen.
Keiner mehr da. Muss ich mal eben meinen Computer wieder reaktivieren, weil ich natürlich den Namen jetzt wieder vergessen habe. Der hat nämlich gerade den Screen-Schnipel runter gemacht in dem Moment.
Simon!
Ah schade, Simon ist nicht mehr da. Hat mal an blinden Studenten betreut in seiner Zivi-Zeit. Das wäre jetzt auch nochmal spannend gewesen, so aus der helfenden Perspektive in dem Punkt ein bisschen was zu erzählen, aber der hat wahrscheinlich nicht so lange warten wollen. Vielleicht können wir das Thema ja noch einen Tacken weiter drehen, wenn wir jetzt den Simon nicht mehr haben und zu einem anderen Aspekt übergehen, des semantischen Web.
Ja, also es gibt verschiedene, also das Schöne ist, das Web ist jetzt zu alt. Wie alt ist es denn jetzt eigentlich? Zwölf Jahre im Prinzip, also in der allgemeinen Wahrnehmung ist es natürlich noch sehr viel jünger. Also richtig angefangen hat das von 95, 96. Aber jetzt ist schon so ein bestimmter Zeitraum verstrichen, wo man sagen kann, man hat seine ersten Erfahrungen gemacht. Und es setzen sich halt jetzt Sachen durch, wie die Leute auch wirklich das Web benutzen möchten. Also man kann jetzt klar erkennen, wo der tatsächliche Nutzen ist und wo nur der Hype irgendwie eine große Rolle gespielt hat. Und was derzeit, also was eigentlich schon von Anfang an immer ein Trend war, aber der jetzt auch mehr und mehr als Trend auch deutlich zu erkennen, es ist etwas, was man unter dem Stichwort Webblogs oder Blogs zusammenfasst. Das ist so salopp formuliert, so ein bisschen das Tagebuch im Web. Eigentlich nur eine simple Webseite, wo man eben von Zeit zu Zeit, zweimal am Tag, zweimal die Woche, zweimal im Monat, ein, zwei, drei Absätze zu was auch immer niederschreibt. Und das macht dann halt jeder für sich. Und die eigentliche Kraft liegt darin, dass es eben ganz viele Leute auf dieselbe Art und Weise tun. Für Web-Logs gibt es sehr interessante Web-Dienstleister. Da wäre zum Beispiel zu nennen blogger.com. Das gehört zu den etwas bekannteren Systemen. Das Prinzip ist immer dasselbe. Man kann sich da halt einfach eintragen, nicht selten eben auch kostenlos. Und kriegt dann so ein einfaches Web-Interface. Teilweise gibt es auch Programme, die man dann unter seinem Betriebssystem laufen lassen kann, um das zu tun. Aber man hat ein einfaches Interface, in dem man eben einfach so einen Log, so ein News-Item, so ein, ein, zwei absetzte Text zu was auch immer absetzen kann. Das wird dann eben mit einem Datum, also mit so einem Zeitstempel oben an die Seite gesetzt und alle anderen Meldungen rutschen halt einfach nach unten. Klingt natürlich jetzt nicht so besonders aufregend. Das besonders bemerkenswerte ist erstens, sehr viele Leute tun das. Und dadurch wird eben dieses, von wem war es noch gleich? Von Herrn Brecht?
Die Radiotheorie. Ja, jeder ist ein Sender.
Genau, jeder ist ein Sender. Das wird dadurch eigentlich aktiv befördert. Wir haben das schon von Anfang an immer nach vorne gestellt, hier im Chaosradio vor langer, langer Zeit. Und damals war es natürlich einfach auch technisch noch sehr aufwendig für Leute wirklich was zu publizieren. Klar, da hat man sich so an die Homepage gemacht. Das ist dann meistens so ein Wochenendeaktion und dann hat man irgendwas fertig, aber selten wird es gepflegt. Und dieses regelmäßige Pflegen, dieses regelmäßige Nachliefern von Nachrichten, das ist mittlerweile so einfach geworden, dass es eben auch kräftig getan wird. Und was dadurch entsteht, ist eigentlich ein Web im Web. Eine Vermaschung, die jetzt über den einfachen Link hinausgeht. Leute beziehen sich auf die einzelnen Kommentare in anderen Logs. Und die Weblog-Systeme machen zum Beispiel auch sehr einfach, dass man in seine Seite nicht nur einen Link auf irgendeine andere Meldung machen kann oder auf irgendeine andere Webseite. Sondern dass man eben auch sagen kann, okay, die Leute, die ich kenne, die haben auch Weblogs. Und Links auf deren Weblogs pack ich gleich mit auf meine Seite drauf. Sodass wenn man irgendwo erstmal einsteigt und sieht, oh, der Typ hat ja wirklich was zu sagen, der hat für diesen und jenen Bereich einen interessanten Standpunkt, das interessiert mich oder zumindest finde ich es mal diskussionswürdig, was er so bringt. Und dann sehe ich halt auch, auf wen er noch so verweist. Und klicke mich da halt weiter durch und tauche dann sozusagen ein ganz eigenes Netz von Verwebungen ein, was mir so das nackte Web als solches eben nicht bietet.
Aber ich meine, es hört sich jetzt so an wie das Paradies, aber wenn alle möglichen Leute da unheimlich viel schreiben, wie du ja auch gesagt hast, ist da nicht auch wieder unheimlich viel Bullshit dabei? Also so dieses klassische Hab heute schon wieder Schnitzel gegessen, morgen werd ich Pommes nehmen und so?
Auch wenn das einer als wichtig erachtet, dass er das berichtet, warum nicht, so ich meine, auch diese Information kann nützlich sein. Aber das ist ja egal, sollen die Leute doch schreiben, was sie wollen, weil letztlich ist es eben auch so, diese Webblogs werden von Google durchsucht und es gibt eben sehr viele davon. Und die Suchmaschinen, also die Google, die basieren ihre Wertung vor allem darauf, wie oft auf irgendetwas verlinkt wird. Das heißt, wenn irgendetwas auch in der Sichtweise von vielen Leuten als wichtig erachtet wird, dann steigt es eben automatisch in seiner Bewertung nach oben, dadurch dass eben viele Leute darauf linken. Und so mischt sich Suchmaschinen und eben auch so dieses Direktlink-System zu einem Konglomerat, was einen sehr hohen Nutzen hat. Also ich habe aus Weblogs schon sehr viel Informationen herausholen können. Und vor allem, es ist so ein bisschen der Journalismus des kleinen Mannes, oder vielleicht auch des einzelnen Journalisten, oder zumindest auch des Augenzeugen. Man kann eben sehr einfach über etwas berichten.
Wobei der kleine Mann eine Information weitergeben kann, die wird dann ganz groß. Eine Information wird an den nächsten, der gibt sie an den übernächsten weiter. Und so entsteht dann eben das Web. Und für uns auch wieder eine ganz andere Vorstellung von Web. Es sind nicht nur die einzelnen isolierten Webseiten, die ich ansurfe, deren URL ich weitergebe, die dann über Google gefunden werden, sondern die Information zirkuliert. Und dadurch entsteht für uns ein ganz anderes Verständnis vom Web. Das Web als Art Universum. Und das Beispiel, was du gerade erwähnt hast, das hab heute Pommes gegessen, morgen gibt's Currywurst, findet natürlich auch den Platz in diesem Universum eben ganz außen. Ein kleiner einzelner Punkt, der schwach leuchtet. Im Zentrum des Universums sind dann die ganz großen Sites, die wir angesprochen haben.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Wurst-Boutique angekommen.
Ja, und dann flacht das so langsam ab. Dann gibt es die mittelgroßen Sites, die Informationen von den Kleinen beziehen, die Informationen an die Großen weitergeben. Wie im Radio auch. Du bekommst deine Informationen von der Nachrichtenagentur, verbreitest die über das Radio draußen in die Welt etc. Also das ist das Informationsuniversum durch das Web.
Es gibt da auch schöne Geschichten. Zum Beispiel gab es irgendjemand, der einen Webblog unterhält und der hatte Stress mit einer Firma, die hieß Critical IP. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, was die angeboten haben, wahrscheinlich ein Internet Service Provider. Auf jeden Fall hat er sich mit der Hotline da ein bisschen verkracht und die waren alle total scheiße. Sein Kommentar war auf seinem Webblog Critical IP sucks. Da er sich ein bisschen rächen wollte, hat er alle seine Webblog-Freunde aufgefordert, doch bitte auch dieses Statement abzusetzen und auf seinen Eintrag zu verweisen. Das Ergebnis war eine Lawine von untereinander Critical IP sucks verlinkten Geschichten, sodass es dann nicht lange dauerte nach wenigen Wochen, dass wenn man eben Critical IP bei Google eingab, dass also die ersten zehn Ergebnisse alle nur irgendwie Critical IP sucks von sich gab.
Bevor überhaupt die Adresse der Firma kam.
Genau. Das ist dann irgendwie auch ein bisschen bekannt geworden als Google Bombs, sodass man sozusagen Google durch diese top aktuellen, mit vielen Links ausgestatteten Sachen im Prinzip wichtige Sachen unterschieben kann, die dann die eigentliche Information beiseite schieben. Aber das kann man ja auch anders sehen. Es ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch eine Information.
Fertig Gerelierer aus.
Die Link Farms.
Und es gibt jetzt Maßnahmen bei Google, wie sie das so ein bisschen eindämmen wollen. Aber wenn man jetzt Critical IP eingibt, kriegt man immer noch als zweiten Link oder so einen IP sucks ab.
Großartig. Das ist ja wirklich wie ein Gerilliatum fast schon, dass man das auch dann noch erreichen kann.
Interessant finde ich übrigens, dass Google vor einer Woche Blogger, diese größte Weblog-Company, gekauft hat.
Ah, interessant. Gibt es da noch andere? Im blogger.com ist das so, dass das eine internationale Geschichte ist. Das heißt, ich werde auch mit englischen Sachen konfrontiert oder kann ich sagen, ich möchte gerne nur deutsche Beiträge haben?
Du schreibst ja die Beiträge. Das ist ja nur eine Maschine, die dir das Unterhalten einer Weblog-Webseite ermöglicht.
Aber jetzt nur für Leute, die da einsteigen wollen. Wenn ich mit dahingehe, erwarten mich dann hauptsächlich internationale User oder treffe ich auch ein paar deutsche?
User, das sind gar keine User. Das ist einfach nur eine Maschine, mit der du deine Webseite bauen kannst.
Ja, aber weil du gesagt hast, da sind viele, die auch zu anderen Weblogs verlinken?
Ja, nur Leute finden halt so dich wie sie sonst irgendwelche Seiten finden. Also entweder du hast mal was kluges geschrieben und die Leute finden es eine Suchmaschine oder es wird halt weiter empfohlen. Es gibt auch sehr viele deutsche Weblogs. Wir haben da auch gleich nochmal einen interessanten Kandidaten, den wir dazu nochmal befragen wollen. Aber es gibt auch nicht nur Blogger. Es gibt auch andere Tools, die auch softwaremäßig anders funktionieren. Blogger ist halt rein websitebasiert. Es gibt dann auch noch Radio Userland. Das ist auch noch zu erwähnen von diesem verrückten Dave Weiner, der auch in dieser ganzen Scripting- und Weblogging-Community kein unbekannter Name ist. Der ist auch ein ganz eigenwilliger Couts in der Internetwelt. Radio Userland ist eine Software, die läuft auf Mac und Windows. Da kann man sich relativ einfach sehr gepflegte Weblogs unterhalten.
Das ist aber ein richtiges Programm, das läuft nicht über einen Browser.
Das ist ein richtiges Programm. Das konfiguriert man zwar auch mit einem Browser, aber man ist dann auch selber Server.
Weil wir jetzt schon mal erklärt haben, worum es geht, könnten wir im Grunde leichter dazu übergehen, Jörg Cantl anzurufen, der ein deutsches Weblog unterhält und uns dann vielleicht noch mal aus der Macher-Sicht erklären kann, was für Herausforderungen man da so gestellt ist. Solange gibt es ein bisschen Musik im Chaosradio mit Arne, Tim und Max von Gregor, der im Hintergrund fleißig sein DJ Set weiter auflegt. Das gehört nicht das Jazz-Radio, das ist das Chaos-Radio. Da kann sowas aber durchaus mal vorkommen, wenn der Gregor auflegt. Das ist auch erfrischend und es ist keine Fahrstuhlmusik. So viel kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Heute Abend geht es im Chaos-Radio mit Arne, Tim und meiner Person Max um das Semantische Web. Und das Semantische Web lasse ich Tim oder Arne immer wieder erklären, weil die das wunderbar in zwei Halbsitzen auf den vollen Begriff bringen können.
Ja, das Web wurde bisher von Menschen gelesen. Jetzt sollen auch Maschinen das Web lesen können. Aber das Maschinen lesbare Webmaschinen, die uns dann dienen, um uns zu den Informationen unmittelbar zu führen, die wir suchen.
Und die interessantere Information, das hat Tim vorhin angedeutet, bevor wir ein bisschen Musik gehört haben, findet sich in sogenannten Weblogs.
Und weil wir da viel darüber erzählen können, aber es immer noch besser ist, die Leute, die das konkret auch selber schon längere Zeit tun zu fragen, haben wir jetzt mal den Jörg Kärntl angerufen. Du betreibst das Weblog, das bekannt ist, unter der Schockwellenreiter, unter www.schockwellenreiter.de. Ich habe hier mal ein bisschen rumgeklickt. Hier ist irgendwie ein interessanter Lebenslauf von dir zu finden. Jahrgang 53, verheiratet und Berufe in Reihenfolge, Speditionskaufmann, Gitarrist, Schüler, Student, Programmierer, Kabarettist, Systembetreuer, Systemanalytiker, bis hin zu EDV-Leiter. Was hat man in der Welt so zu erzählen, wenn man irgendwie mit der Bandbreite am Start ist?
Ja, was hat man der Welt zu erzählen? Also ich habe irgendwann mal das Ganze charakterisieren müssen und da habe ich gesagt, das ist ein Weblog über Gott und die Welt, den Apple Macintosh, Skript Sprachen und mich.
Das Ganze heißt dann im Untertitel die tägliche Ration Wahnsinn. Wie viel Wahnsinn wirst du denn dann sozusagen als Betreiber konfrontiert?
Also als Betreiber konfrontiert werde ich glaube eher seltener mit Wahnsinn. Also ich glaube, den Wahnsinn produziere ich schon selber. Ja, es gibt eine Menge Feedback. Das hängt aber auch immer von den Tagen und von den Themen ab. Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel schon auf diese Sendung E-Mails bekommen. Also das geht schon Feedback zurück.
Erklär doch mal für alle, die jetzt auch erst eingestiegen sind, was macht man auf deiner Seite? Was passiert auf schockwellenreiter.de?
Ja, ich bekomme Nachrichten täglich rein. Also ich bekomme zwischen 500 und 1000 Nachrichten täglich rein. Dann suche ich die aus, die ich für interessant halte, die ich für interessant finde und die stelle ich dann in meinen Weblog. Das sind so zwischen 25 und 30 pro Tag.
Und du liest diese 500 bis 1000 Teile?
Nein, also die bekommen über ein RSS Feed rein, wo das Thema ja Semantisches Web und automatisches Lesen ist. Also das heißt, ich habe sozusagen Schlachtzeilen, Headlines abonniert und ich gucke erstmal mit bestimmten RSS-Riedern. Also zurzeit benutze ich Netnews via Lite, aber davor hatte ich auch das vorhin schon mal erwähnte Radio Usaland benutzt. Gucke ich mir halt diese Sachen an und dann klicke ich mich in die Seiten, wo ich die Überschrift oder die ersten Zeilen schon interessant finde, klicke ich mich rein. Weil also so viel kann ich morgens nicht lesen, also das schaffe ich nicht. Also Radio Usaland da ein kleines bisschen besser war als jetzt dieses Net News, weil das hatte die gesamte Nachricht angezeigt, also alle 500 auf einer Seite, das war zwar eine riesige lange Seite, aber da die Lokal bei mir auf dem Rechner war hinreichend schnell, man hat einen schnelleren Überblick mit Durchscrollen und dann guckt man eben halt nach. Und im Laufe der, ich mache das ja nun jetzt schon fast drei Jahre, im Laufe dieser Zeit hat man ein gewisses Gefühl dafür, von welchem Bereich man interessante Nachrichten bekommt und wo nicht.
Das Publizieren hat da auch schon mal so ein paar unangenehme Konsequenzen mit dem Verlag Surkamp?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, es war eher etwas lustiger. Der Surkamp-Verlag hat halt versucht mich abzumahnen, weil ich auf einen Link gesetzt hatte, auf die im Web kursierende Raubkopie des Walzer Machwerks. Ich war der Meinung, der Surkamp-Verlag ist selber schuld, wenn er an alle Journalisten per PDF dieses Ding schickt, dann muss er sich nicht wundern, dass es im Web landet. Gut, dann habe ich diese Abmahnung bekommen und dann habe ich halt reingeschrieben Skandal. Der Surkamp-Verlag treibt armen Blogger in den Ruinen, das war am Freitagabend. Und am Wochenende ging dann ein Rauschen auch durch den Blätterwald. Und am Montag hat der Surkamp-Verlag angerufen. Und dann habe ich mit dem Geschäftsführer des Surkamp-Verlages ein, wie er es so schön genannt hat, ein offenes Gespräch geführt. Und danach wurde die Abmahnung, er sagt nicht zurückgezogen, sondern er sagt immer, es wurde auf die Eintreibung der Forderung verzichtet. Aber es läuft doch gleich heraus.
Hat dann das Weblog sozusagen auch schon eine gewisse Macht an der Stelle entwickelt, was sozusagen die Öffentlichkeitswirksamkeit betrifft?
Also ich hab's noch nicht genau hinterfragt, aber es scheint so etwas zu sein, weil ich habe den Eindruck, dass ich sehr viel auch von Journalisten gelesen werde und dass dadurch dann eben auch schon wieder ein gewisser Multiplikationsfaktor eintritt. Also von der eigenen Besucherzahl her, ich hab zwischen 2.000 und 3.000 Besucher pro Tag, kann ich noch nicht sagen, dass das eine Macht ist.
Aber das ist natürlich schon eine ganz ordentliche Zahl.
Ja, ich find das auch schon ganz schön, es macht ja auch Spaß, so viele Leser zu haben.
Auf jeden Fall. Und wie viele andere Weblogs, ich weiß nicht, gibt es irgendwelche Weblogs, die du jetzt wirklich noch liest, oder ist das jetzt eigentlich schon wirklich nur noch so ein RSS-Abklappern geworden? Also inwieweit nimmt man jetzt wirklich noch Teil an den anderen?
Ja, man hat schon noch sozusagen befreundete Weblogs, die man auch tatsächlich liest. Aber das sind natürlich nicht die Mengen, die ich als RSS-Biet reinnehme. Oder eben halt auch, es müssen nicht nur befreundete Weblogs sein, es können auch Weblogs sein, über die ich mich besonders ärgere, die ich dann natürlich auch lese, damit ich auch irgendwas habe, woran ich mich reiben kann und dann wieder was entsprechend schreiben.
Wie bist du auf die Idee gekommen eigentlich, das Ding so aufzuziehen? Weil es ja schon, also mittlerweile, wenn man sich das anguckt, unter www.shockwellenreiter.de, es ist eine ganze Menge. Es macht wahrscheinlich auch, wenn man anfängt damit und jetzt noch nicht so die Perfektion darin entwickelt hat, eine ganze Menge Arbeit. Wann hast du dich dafür entschieden und warum?
Ja, das ist also entschieden. Ich habe einen Webblock gesehen, vor, wie gesagt, vor ca. drei Jahren. Fand das toll, weil das das ist, was ich eigentlich auch immer machen wollte. So Informationen von unten, völlig uncensiert, ohne in irgendwelche Produktionsmittel gebunden zu sein. Und das war ein Manila-Webblock. Also Manila ist auch eine dieser Software, die ich vorhin schon erwähnte, verrückte, die Ed Weiner produziert hat. Hab mich also dann da, hat mir auch so ein Manila-Webblock erstmal besorgt. Dann lief das noch unter der Schockwellenreiter Edit this Page kommen. Dann hab ich ein Wochenende gebastelt und dann stand das Teil.
Aber jetzt ist es nicht mehr Manila, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne?
Also Manila hatte, ich nenne das das Manila-Syndrom, ein Problem unter dem vermutlich alle freien Hosts, die also kostenlos anbieten, solche Weblogs zu führen, leiden, also Blogger hat da auch schon mal drunter gelitten, dass einfach wegen Überfüllung langsam wird, der Server überlastet wird dann dabei. Und dann kam dieses Radio Userland raus und da hab ich mir halt Radio Userland besorgt und hab das dann bis vor wenigen Wochen mit Radio Userland gemacht, dann auf einem, dabei bei einem der großen deutschen Provider gehostet. So ein Premium-Account gehostet dann eben halt. Ja und vor einigen Wochen ist mir dann Radio Userland unwiderbringlich abgeschmiert hier auf meinem Rechner nach einem Betriebssystem-Update und seitdem mach ich das mit einer selbstbestrickten Software. Da weiß ich wenigstens, was ich hab.
Mit Python seh ich das richtig?
Ja, in Python. Python ist eine Skript-Sprache.
Ja, schick. Beeindruckend. Gibt's denn, also ich meine inwieweit fühlt man sich denn da, ich meine, ich hab ja vorhin so ein bisschen die These aufgestellt, dass es noch mal so eine ganz eigene Meta-Community ist, die sich jetzt bei diesen Weblogs rausstellt. Und man hört ja nun stellenweise auch, dass es, sagen wir mal, eine neue Form des Journalismus ist, die da mitgefördert wird. Würdest du das irgendwie unterstreichen?
Also das eine ja, das andere nicht. Also es gibt irgendwie Weblogs in einer Community. Das hab ich auch in einigen Aufsätzen geschrieben. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, warum das so ist. Also bei einigen Sachen ist es klar, also zum Beispiel es gibt einen großen freien Host in Österreich, Arndtville, der allerdings auch schon dicht machen musste wegen Überfüllung. Neuer freier Weblogs bekommt man da nicht. Die haben durch eine Art Community, weil sie alle auf dem gleichen Server sind. Also mit der gleichen Maschine, mit der gleichen Software arbeiten, da auch die gleichen Probleme haben, weil man dann auch immer auf einer, auf der Startseite dieses Servers sieht, welche Weblogs frisch abgedatet haben, man immer dann da reinklicken kann. Wenn man da also dann drauf geht, sieht man, also was weiß ich, die, wenn man mal ein Elefant will, hat neu abgedatet, klickt man rauf, ist man immer schnell da, hat eine gewisse Community dabei. Neue Formen des Journalismus würde ich eher nicht sagen. Noch zumindest sind Weblogs typische Zweitverwerter. Also wir bekommen die Information aus dem journalistischen Bereich. Wir, also zumindest der Schockwerdenreiter bringt ja auch im Prinzip nur den Link auf diese Information, im besten Falle mit einem knackigen Kommentar. Die eigentliche journalistische Arbeit läuft doch noch bei den Journalisten ab.
Was hältst du von sowas? Im Grunde machen die ja nichts anderes. Es gibt eine relativ bekannte Seite, die das auch macht, die nennt sich perlentaucher.de, die im Grunde linked ist. Das sind ja professionellere, glaube ich in einem Team arbeitende Leute, die auch immer ein bisschen was dazuschreiben, die auch sehr, sehr gut organisiert sind. Liest du dir das manchmal durch?
Ja, perlentaucher gehört auch mit zu meinen Seiten, die ich regelmäßig lese.
Ist der im Grunde sowas wie ein professionelles Weblog, wenn man so will?
Ja, im Grunde ist es so etwas, ja ja. Es hat nur einen etwas anderen Anspruch, glaube ich, als den Anspruch, den dein Weblog hatte. Ich finde perlentaucher immer, es fehlt in gewisser Hinsicht auch das Unterhaltende dabei. Es ist eigentlich nur das Suchen nach, ja im Regelfall eher literarischen Quellen und literarischen Links. Das ist ein bisschen der Spaß an der Freude, habe ich den da. Also es ist für mein Gefühl zu kommerziell angesetzt, also nicht zu professionell angesetzt. Irgendwie fehlt der Charme, den so ein Weblog hat.
Suchst du da andere Weblogs auch nach dieser Art von Charme aus, also dass du sagst, oh, das ist ein Proll, bei dem gehe ich auf jeden Fall nochmal auf die Seite. Der mag Frauen und schnelle Autos oder so, auch wenn du das selber nicht magst zum Beispiel.
Ja, in der Hinsicht schon, ja, natürlich. Ich hab zum Beispiel einen Weblog oder mehrere Weblogs, die sich mehr mit kommerziellen Themen beschäftigen. Da reib ich mich immer ganz gerne dran.
Hast du noch ein paar gute Tipps irgendwie für den interessierten Klicker?
Ja, also eins meiner zurzeit absoluten Lieblings-Weblogs sind einmal die Industrial Technology und Witchcraft mit der vermutlich längsten URL der Welt, eben halt auch unter der Blogger-Szene zumindest, die heißen tatsächlich www.industrialtechnologyandwitchcraft.de Das ist ein ganz witziges, also wie ich finde, sehr, sehr witziges Weblog. Dann ein Weblog aus der Arndt-Wil-Szene, das ist Kellerkind, Bogenstraße 11 mit der URL monolock.andwil.org Das kann man ja alles gar nicht so schnell mitzippen. Da muss man ein bisschen übeln. Ein amerikanisches, sehr witziges Blog ist das Boing Boing Blog, www.boingboing.net Bevor wir die jetzt alle aufzählen, findet man die denn auch relativ schnell zugänglich?
Auf irgendwelchen Ecken deiner Seite schockwenreiter.de?
Nur momentan nur unter den...
Du kannst ja gleich noch mal ein Webblog-Update machen, wo die schnell drin sind.
Zurzeit nur unter den einzelnen Einträgen. Ich hab zwar noch eine Linkliste mit Webblogs, also unter Linksammlung findet man die. Die habe ich aber noch mit Radio Userland erstellt und dann mit Radio Userland gecrasht. Jetzt ist die schon Ewigkeit nicht mehr aktualisiert worden. Leider wechselt in der Webblog-Szene noch sehr häufig... Also ist der Umzugsgedanke und der URL-Wechsel noch sehr häufig dann dabei.
Ja, ich würde sagen, wir bedanken uns mal für die Einblicke. Wir treffen uns sicherlich auf der einen oder anderen Meldingsliste wieder.
Ja und ich wünsche dir auch eine schöne Sendung.
Jörg Handel war das, betreibt selber ein Weblog. Und zwar www.schockwellenreiter.de. Wenn ihr euch das mal angucken möchtet, was der Herr so macht. Wie gesagt, schockwellenreiter.de. Einfach mal vorbeisurfen. Ihr hört den Blue Moon auf Fritz. Der Blue Moon auf Fritz. So ein sehr vielfältigen Thema, das sich allerdings im Schafspelz nähert, verkleideterweise das Semantische Web, also vielleicht das, was wir in Zukunft mal haben werden, das Semantische World Wide Web. Thematisch erklären wir das gleich nochmal, da wir jetzt aber eine relativ lange Zeit geredet haben und wir vielleicht auch gleich nochmal mit euch telefonieren möchten. Mit etwas feuchterem Mund und nicht ganz so trockenem Hals gibt es jetzt noch ein bisschen Musik im Chaos Radio von Gregor. Ja, die ganz wirklich großen Erkenntnisse kommen im Chaos Radio ja immer so kurz nach Null Uhr. Ich hab nämlich tatsächlich erfahren, es geht heute Abend um Semantische Web im Chaos Radio und wir haben es hier, das Semantische Web, sie haben es gerade selber zugegeben, Arne und Tim haben festgestellt, oh Gott, wir sind das Semantische Web. Was das Semantische Web ist und warum euch und euch alle in Berlin und Brandenburg, die ihr schon mal gesurft habt, interessieren sollte und wie man das Semantische Web wird, das werden euch Arne und Tim vom Chaos Radio jetzt selber erklären. Habt ihr ja wirklich eine Lanze für euch selber gebrochen, das müsst ihr jetzt erstmal wieder gut machen. Auf jeden Fall, aber so kann ich euch dazu bringen, mir die ganze Sache nochmal zu erklären.
Tim, du wolltest noch was ankündigen.
Ach ja, wir haben ja noch was anderes, bevor wir jetzt sozusagen zu sehr hier gleich wieder die Technik fallen. Also wer auch das Semantische Web werden will, hat vielleicht im August dieses Jahres dazu eine Gelegenheit, denn wir brechen gerade auf zu einer Unternehmung, die wir vor vier Jahren schon mal gemacht haben. Das Chaos Communication Camp wird sein, eine viertägige Open Air Hacker Veranstaltung, nicht nur für Hacker, die in der Nähe von Berlin stattfinden wird und wo man mit dem Zelt einziehen kann und vier Tage Spaß haben kann. Das wird so vom 7. bis zum 10. August stattfinden und viele Details gibt es noch nicht, aber wenn es sie gibt, dann gibt es sie unter www.cccde.com Da gibt es jetzt schon so eine Ankündigungsseite und die Möglichkeit sich in Mailinglisten einzutragen und wen das interessiert, der sollte das vielleicht auch tun. Das mal so als kleiner Werbe-Jingle zwischendurch.
Aber ihr seid ja das Semantische Web.
Wir sind ja das Semantische Web. Aber Jörg ist natürlich auch das Semantische Web, weil er hat ja auch ein paar Buzzwords fallen lassen, da wollen wir auch gerne noch mal auf das eine oder andere eingehen.
Der Herr, den wir gerade am Telefon hatten, der selber einen Weblog erstellt unter der Adresse shopwennrad.de.
Der berichtete, dass er sozusagen seine Nachrichten aus einem RSS Newsfeed bezieht.
Habe ich auch wieder nicht verstanden.
Genau, und das ist nämlich sozusagen auch der eigentliche Sport, der derzeit betrieben wird. Diese Weblogs, die haben ja alle was gemeinsam. Die haben ja alle so die gleiche Art und Weise des Publizierens. Da ist aber also ein kurzes News-Item, also so eine kurze Meldung, irgendwie ein ein, zwei, drei Sätze Kommentar zu irgendetwas und dazu eine oder mehrere Links. Und da die eben alle so ähnlich sind, ist es eben auch sehr einfach, dafür ein ja, ein sehr einfaches spezielles Format zu machen, was nämlich genau diese Kerninformation, Datum, Wann, Was, Link und so weiter, das alles in eine Datei zu packen, die eben ganz speziell ausgezeichnet ist, sodass sie eben sehr maschinenlesbar wird. Das Format, was dort verwendet wird, nennt sich RSS. Da gibt es verschiedene Erklärungen dafür, was das bedeutet. Manche nennen das Rich Site Summary, also reiche, im englischen Wortsinne von Rich, also umfangreiche Zusammenfassung einer Seite. Standardsliebenden würden es eher RDF Site Summary nennen, und das bezieht sich dann wiederum auf eine andere Abkürzung, nämlich RDF. Das ist das Resource Description Framework und das ist tatsächlich der Standard, der eigentlich das Semantische Web in Zukunft ausmachen wird und heute im Prinzip die Basis für alle kommenden Standards in diesem Bereich setzt.
Nun seid ihr beide, das muss man sagen, die Urväter der Chaosradio-Seite. Du, Tim, hast die erste geschrieben und gescriptet und du, Arne, die zweite Version dieser Seite. Und ihr wart immer schon...
Na ja, nicht der Chaosradio-Seite, sondern der...
Ja. Der, Selbst die Begrifflichkeit ist klar. Es gab da unterschiedliche Versionen. 0.9 ist eine RDF Sites summary und die 0.9.1 eine Ridge Sites summary. Die 1.0 ist wieder eine RDF Sites summary. Aber was ist das RSS und RDF? Wie fing das Ganze an? Ursprünglich im Jahr 1999, früher noch 1997, 1998, fing Netscape an, ein Portal aufzubauen. Jeder dachte noch an einzelne Seiten. Ich kann meine Seite ins Netz stellen, habe isoliert Informationen. Netscape fing an, ein Portal ins Netz zu stellen.
My Channel?
Sie hatten an diesem Portal Informationen weiter verteilt. Diese Informationen, Jörg hat das beim Schockwellenrad doch sehr gut erklärt, diese Informationen fliegen morgens früh ein, 500 bis 1000 oder sogar noch viel mehr werden sortiert. Die Links bilden dann das Portal. Das sind Quellen, RSS-Quellen. Diese Quellen bieten Links, bieten Beschreibungen, die ich dann in meine Seite direkt integrieren kann. Möchte ich den gesamten Text lesen, klicke ich auf den Link und komme dann zu der originales Seite. Das Portal ist nur die Einstiegsmöglichkeit in eine weitere Welt des Webs. Diese RSS Newsfeeds von Netscape und dem Herrn Dave Weiner, der dann mit scriptingnews.com die Blogs ins Leben gerufen hat. Ein sehr gutes Beispiel einer Verwertung von Commerzial Insights ist www.salonherringwiredfool.com. Wir haben vier sehr große Informationsanbieter im Netzsalon. Red Herring, Wired und Motley Fool. Die Informationen werden gesammelt. Diese Informationen werden dann auf dieser einen Seite weiterverteilt. RSS ist dazu die Basistechnologie. Diese einzelnen Sites bieten von ihren Inhalten eine Beschreibung an. Eine einzelne Datei, die abgerufen werden kann. In dieser Datei steht eben, ich hab es gerade gesagt, der Link zu der Originalquelle, der Titel und eine kurze Beschreibung. Das macht RSS aus und das kann gelesen werden. Ich kann natürlich mehrere Newsfeeds, mehrere derartige Newsfeeds lesen, kann die sortieren, dem Datum nach und habe dann unterschiedliche Quellen auf meiner Seite zu einer anderen Quelle, zu einer weitergehenden Quelle vereinigt.
Um das vielleicht nochmal etwas zu simplifizieren. Eigentlich ist es ganz einfach. Mit RSS kann man den Inhalt seines Webblogs ganz einfach in einer einzigen Datei zusammenfassen. Die packt man auf seine Webseite. Und andere Leute können die dann eben beziehen. Zum Beispiel mit einem speziellen RSS-Rider. Da gibt es für jedes Betriebssystem verschiedene. Der Jörg hat vorhin eines erwähnt für den Mac, das ist dieses Net News Wire. Es gibt auch welche im Web, zum Beispiel Meerkat von O'Reilly. Bei oreilly.com/meerkat, da schreibt sich M-Doppel-E-R-K-A-T. Das ist so ein webbasierter RSS-Leser. Auch dieses Radio UserLand, was wir schon erwähnt haben. userland.com, also radio.userland.com kann das auch. Und es gibt noch ganz viele Tools. Bei Windows gibt es auch diverse, aber die weißen natürlich wieder alle nicht. Aber das ist eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem, da geht man irgendwie auf seine Lieblingssoftware-Update-Seite und sucht einfach mal nach RSS-Readern. Und man wird schnell überrascht sein, wie viele RSS-Feeds es schon gibt. Also es sind wirklich Tausende. Ich hab heute auch noch mal vor der Sendung irgendwie angefangen, mir mal so ein paar Listen zusammenzustellen. Und es ist einfach unglaublich convenient, also unglaublich einfach und praktisch. Man kriegt halt einfach schnell so, gerade auch über Seiten, die man vielleicht so ohnehin schon immer gelesen hat, wo man dann stundenlang durch irgendwelche Meldungen durchgeblättert hat, einfach sehr schnell einen Überblick.
Bis man die Meldung gefunden hat, die einen dann tatsächlich interessiert. Und so fliegen die ganzen Newsfeeds, die RSS-Feeds fliegen dann rein, werden vom Client angezeigt, ich habe den schnellen Überblick und lese dann die Nachrichten, die mich wirklich interessieren. Machen wir Werbung für uns, www.ccc.de slash updates slash chaosupdates.rdf Das ist unser Newsfeed. Hier werden die Updates, die auf der Startseite zu erkennen sind, in Form eines RDFs angeboten. Können von den Newsreadern, die Tim gerade genannt hat gelesen werden, können in andere Sites eingebunden werden. Ja und so verteilen wir unsere Informationen. Chaos, Chaos Everywhere.
Und da ihr das Semantische Web seid, um diesen Begriff einfach nochmal einzufügen, habt ihr das ja schon seit Ewigkeiten so im Grunde, oder?
Tim hatte die erste Version der Webseiten gemacht. Das war vor einigen Jahren.
Das war noch brutale Handarbeit.
Äußerst brutal war diese Handarbeit. Das führte dazu, dass sehr viele Leute daran beteiligt waren, beteiligt werden wollten. Und es gab am Schluss, ich würde sagen, Chaos. Wir hatten einen Informationsstamm, einen Dateistamm, der war dann kaum noch zu überblicken. Das ist meine Einschätzung. Wir haben gesagt, da müssen wir Karl schlagen. Wir müssen uns mit Technologien anfreunden, die hier unseren Produktions- und Informationsgegebenheiten dann doch etwas genüge tun, sind abgekommen von HTML. Die Seite läuft nicht mehr auf HTML, die Seite läuft auf XML. Derart, dass wir die vielen Texte, die HTML bietet, sehr viele überflüssige, willkürliche Information innerhalb der HTML-Text ersetzt haben durch eine eigene XML-Sprache. Wir haben Text selber definiert, haben nur die Text definiert, die wir brauchen und kommen zu einem Dateienstamm, der erheblich konsistenter ist und auch schneller in andere Formate zu übertragen ist. Wir können aus diesen XML-Dateien in Windows-Eile HTML erzeugen. Das machen wir on the fly. Wir können aus den XML-Dateien Text-Dateien erzeugen. Wir können PDFs erzeugen. Wir können RDFs erzeugen. Und das alles eben, weil wir uns verständigt haben auf ein universelles Format. Jetzt waren wir gerade bei XML. Vorher waren wir bei RSS. Das sind die zwei wesentlichen Technologien für das Semantische Web.
Ihr seid schon ein paar Füchse, oder?
Ach, das ist eigentlich alles ganz normales Wassergekoche, was wir da machen. Wenn man sich irgendwie ein bisschen mit der Technik auseinandersetzt, dann ist das so ein bisschen die logische Konsequenz. Also XML, ich sag's immer gern, ist irgendwie das TCPIP der Datenformate. Das heißt, auch TCPIP war mal vor einiger Zeit für viele Leute noch irgendwie ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln, und heute irgendwie kennt es hier das Kind. Und mit XML ist es halt auch nicht anders. Es ist einfach mal eine praktische Lösung, um strukturierte Daten zu speichern. Und die setzt sich gerade überall durch. Also auch das nächste Word macht alles in XML und das ganze Web basiert auf XML. Das ist einfach eine Vereinfachung für die Maschinenlesbarkeit, weil es sehr einfach ist, für ein Programm XML zu lesen. Und darauf setzen dann alle neuen Standards auf.
Betriebssysteme setzen auf XML. Meco S10 zum Beispiel schreibt sehr viel in XML.
Bevor wir uns jetzt wieder komplett in eine andere Richtung entfernen, würde ich ja gerne nochmal die Hörer zu Wort kommen lassen, euch in Berlin und Brandenburg zu den Themen, die wir schon angesprochen haben. Und da sind einige gewesen, unter anderem eben Weblogs. Bevor wir uns davon entfernen, vielleicht mal eben die Nati am Telefon. Aus Berlin, hallo Nati.
Hallo, ich bin übrigens der. Kein Problem.
Ja, war so, hörte sich so freundlich an und dachte, vielleicht ist es ja auch eine Name.
Ja, also ich finde Weblogs auch daher sehr praktisch, da sie es einfach sehr einfachen. Wenn eine Seite was Neues anbietet, fällt ja meistens nicht besonders auf. Da guckt man in den Links rum und irgendwo sieht man, ach, da ist ja was Neues. Aber bei einem Weblog kann eben jeder Webmaster schnell mal angeben, ja ich hab jetzt was Neues, hier ein Direktlink dazu und da kann man sich das downloaden oder so rum.
Welche Weblogs liest du so jeden Tag?
Also auf den Seiten, auf denen ich so unterwegs bin, ist eigentlich überall ein Weblog und ich kenn's gar nicht anders. Also gleich schon als Startseite, dann ist es dort, wer es nicht lesen will, der kann es gleich überspringen, ist ja kein Problem. Und da steht dann eben drinnen, ja, das ist jetzt mal rausgekommen, guckt mal, hier haben wir Infos und alles Mögliche.
War das bei dir schon immer so?
Nein, also ich hab jetzt erst seit dem Neuesten eine Flatrate und seitdem bin ich auch ziemlich oft im Internet unterwegs. Und früher, als ich noch normal mit 56k drin war, war ich auf nur irgendwelchen Seiten, um schnell mal was zu finden und da war keine Webblogs drin.
Hast du schon mal so Portale benutzt, die ja so lange Zeit mal der Hype waren?
Also mit dem Internet, das mach ich jetzt sowieso erst seit ein paar Jahren, seit ich bei Fritz und Wodam geworden habe. Und damals, also angefangen hat, mit Napscap in der Bücherei, aber da hab ich echt nur reingeguckt und ich fand's langweilig. Ich war auf Fritz.de und das war's dann. Und irgendwann mal hab ich dann eben das Modem bekommen und da war es auch nur irgendwelche Seiten, um Cheats zu suchen.
Für Spiele?
Ja, aber dann hab ich mich von Spielen entfernt, hab angefangen, HTML zu schreiben und alles Mögliche. Und seitdem suche ich eben oft auf Seiten nach dem Quelltext, falls mir irgendein Effekt gefällt oder sowas.
Und hast du mal überlegt, dein eigenes Weblog zu machen?
Ja, das hab ich schon überlegt. Bis jetzt dachte ich eigentlich immer, dass ich heute erfahren habe, dass es nur ein Tabell ist, die man beschreibt, alles mögliche reichheit. Also im Endeffekt ist ja dasselbe, denke ich mal, oder? Sieht irgendwie so aus.
Ja, hängt davon ab, welche Software oder welches Tool du benutzt.
Ja, also da ich mich Weblogs eigentlich nicht so auskennen, sondern sie nur praktisch finde, aber da ich zur Zeit eine Seite schreibe, dachte ich schon, dass ich eine reinsetze.
Kannst du ja mal sowas wie blogger.com anschauen, das ist eigentlich ziemlich idiotensicher und damit kann man schon mal irgendwie das Wesentliche erzielen.
Ja, mach ich da mal rein, aber erst einmal wollte ich sowieso mir die Seite schreiben und dann noch überlegen, ob ich noch was reinsetze oder nicht.
Okay Nati, vielen Dank.
Ich wollte noch etwas sagen zu dem neuen Internet. Da habe ich mal einen Büchereienartikel gelesen, das war irgendwie von 1996, wie sie sich das Internet der Zukunft vorgestellt haben. Und da sprachen sie, was man sich im Internet richtig alles möglich über sich angeben. Und da sucht das Internet überall danach nach, ob jetzt die Lieblingsband ein neues Konzert macht und dass sich dann das Internet auf Arbeit findet oder in der Küche, in die Mikrowelle reinschreibt, eine Band macht ein neues Konzert. So hat sowas auch irgendwie reingeschrieben.
Ja, teilweise gibt es das ja auch schon. Aber das ist ja im Prinzip die gleiche Vision eben dieses in seiner Meinung lesbaren Web, worüber wir die ganze Zeit reden. Auch wenn da manche Leute eher die Idee haben, gib mir alle deine Daten und dann machen wir das für dich. Und wir vertreten eigentlich eher die, das Web gibt uns alle Daten und dann machen wir das alleine.
Ich finde das etwas zu extrem. Ich meine, wenn man da die ganze Zeit alles Mögliche und Licht angibt, das ist ja nun wirklich auch nicht so richtig. Ich hab nicht keine Lust irgendwie im Internet anzugeben, wie meine Telefonnummer und das und das und das. Und wo ich arbeite und dann kann das Internet mich eben überall finden. Mir ist ja im Endeffekt doch egal.
Genau, deswegen machen wir das lieber andersrum. Das Internet gibt uns alles, was es hat und dann können wir selber entscheiden, was wir damit machen.
Ja, das Semantische Web. Danach kommt das Totale Web. Wir gehen alle in den Web.
Web macht frei. Das wär's noch. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie sieht man das mit Communities? Ich hab ja festgestellt, dass wenn man eine definierte Community hat, also wenn man jetzt nicht davon ausgeht, ich möchte gerne das ganze Web für mich in dem Sinne nutzbar machen, sondern ich hab eine bestimmte Community, die sich grundsätzlich schon mal mit dem und dem Thema beschäftigt, also mit Spielen und hab dann Leute, die auch in anderen Bereichen gleichgesinnt sind, hab aber erst mal das Ganze von vornherein so eingeschränkt, dass mir nicht so viel Zeug rechts und links davon auf den Sack geht. Also ich mein, das ist ja im Grunde bei den Webblogs der Fall. Das sind Leute, die schon mal auf dem Style stehen, wie man sich miteinander unterhält, also die Art der Kommunikation.
Wie soll ich das kommentieren jetzt? Mit so einem kleinen Bienchen vielleicht? Ein Bienchen, ein Sternchen würdest du vielleicht haben. Kann ja jeder machen, was er will, im Prinzip, wenn er es nicht übertreibt. Also die Webblogs sind auf jeden Fall ein schönes Phänomen, wie man einfach sehen kann, dass das Web eben jetzt auch wirklich einen Nutzen bekommt über das, was halt bis vor kurzem noch immer so behauptet wurde. Also vor allem dieser unsägliche Trend, das Web nur als Litfasssäule und als Tummelplatz für Firmen zu verstehen, das ist nun Gott sei Dank erstmal gedämpft. Weil das war ja so eine Hysterie am Start. Und dann auch so ein unglaublicher Trend, alles im Sinne der Wirtschaft gesetzmäßig zu gestalten. Was haben wir denn jetzt davon? Viele tausend tote Firmen und tonnenweise Spam. Und das kann halt so nie weitergehen.
Ja, den Begriff der Community, den müssen wir auch nochmal entmystifizieren. Jeder redet immer von der Community im Internet. Wie viel Community ist aber da wirklich? Ich habe Kontakt zum Chaos. Das ist die Chaos-Community. Das sind Leute, die sehe ich regelmäßig. Die sehe ich dann einmal im Jahr auf dem Kongress. Das ist eine echte Community. Leute, die kenne ich. Wir sprechen eigene Sprache. Aber diese Community, wie sie die Medien im Großen skizziert haben, diese Community, wie die Wirtschaft, die sich vorgestellt hat, ich erinnere mich dann an ein Beispiel. Eine bekannte Schokoladenmarke hatte eingerichtet die Lila-Kuh-Community. Was ist daran Community? Das ist lediglich eine Zielgruppe, ein Absatzgebiet. Community ergibt sich darüber hinaus. Und Weblog-Community ist ja eine Gemeinschaft, die sich für eine bestimmte Information interessiert. Die Community der Kleinkaninchenzüchter zum Beispiel.
Ja, und die Community der Kleinkaninchenzüchter kann natürlich auch weiter anrufen unter 033 77 97 110. Der Uwe aus Berlin ist am Telefon und bringt für diese Sendung fast schon einen Klassiker. Hallo Uwe. Das tut uns auch total leid, aber du weißt ja, das gibt ihm höchstens noch ein Stückchen.
Also, die eine Frage habt ihr fast schon beantwortet mit dem XML, weil ich wollte eigentlich fragen, wie sich denn XML da für die Zukunft darstellt. Ich wollte jetzt nur mal wissen, diese definierte Untermenge, die ihr da gemacht habt, oder wie man sagen kann. Also das findet sich aber auf den CCC Seiten irgendwo. Kann man auf dieses Format, das ihr da konstruiert habt, auch zurückgreifen?
Ja, die URL hatten wir gesagt, www.ccc.de slash-updates-slash-chaos-updates.rdf Gut, wollte ich nur wissen.
Das würde dir aber jetzt nichts bringen, wenn du das einfach so in deinen Browser reingibst, sondern das musst du halt schon mit einem RSS-Reader dir anschauen.
Achso, aber auf eurer normalen Webseite ist da schon irgendwie ein Verweis drauf auf das Thema?
Ja, ist es.
Ok, erste Frage beantwortet. Dann war das andere, weil ich hatte gerade gestern so einen interessanten Vorfall, mit Information suchen im Web, zwar in einem Bereich, wo man dachte, man findet die. Ich hab einen Kumpel, das ist auch interessant. Der ist quasi Kommunikationswissenschaftler, hat jetzt Content Manager gelernt, das letzte Jahr. Ich bin mehr Netzwerktechniker und hab ihm jetzt irgendwie beraten, so ein Komplettsystem zusammenzustellen, möglichst aus einer Hand. Und wir wollten halt nur mal ein bisschen gucken, ich sag jetzt den Namen von der Firma nicht, aber anhalter Angebotsliste wollten halt zum Beispiel, nur als Beispiel gucken, eine Grafikkarte, welches ist die preiswerteste, die in Tests auch am besten abschneidet und so weiter und so fort. Und dann suchten wir also zum Beispiel, wo ich gerne hingehe, chip.de. Der erste Schock war der letzte Grafikkartentest, war von Mai 2002. Da war ich ein bisschen geschockt. Ich hab letztes Jahr einen Rechner gekauft und auf denselben Test zurückgegriffen. Also da war keine GeForce 4 so und so zu sehen. Okay, dann haben wir Google eingeschaltet. Hatten auch genau eine Karte im Auge. Er hat uns die, hat uns wieder Chip.de gegeben. Wir sind dahin gegangen. Dann frag ich mich, wie kommt sowas zustande? Es gibt manchmal Suchbegriffe, die findet man. Dann landet man auf der Website, auf der richtigen Unterseite auch. Quasi ist das sogar markiert, der Suchbegriff. Und manchmal landet man auf einer Hauptseite. Und selbst da, auf der internen Suchmaschine, finde ich diese Grafikkarte nicht. Also es taucht auf Google einen Link auf. Aber auf der Seite finde ich den nicht. Ob ich da in Untermenüs gehe? Wo ist da die Information verloren?
Sehr häufig ist es so, dass gerade so Magazine Informationen auf eine URL stellen. Und dann diese eine Seite ändert permanent ihren Content. Dann kommt Google irgendwann vorbei, findet das, indiziert das. Und irgendwie 20 Minuten später ist die Information auf der Seite schon wieder eine ganz andere und kehrt so nie wieder zurück. Es kann auch 20 Tage später sein. Also je nachdem, wie häufig Google das abklappert. Da das Web dann nun mal recht groß ist, braucht auch Google seine Zeit, bis er wieder irgendwo vorbeischaut. Und er schaut sich ja auch nicht alles mit der gleichen Regelmäßigkeit an, sondern er schaut auch, wie häufig sich etwas ändert. Und da gibt es eben so verschiedenste Methodiken, die uns jetzt auch nicht im Detail immer bekannt sind, wie das entscheidet. Aber Tatsache ist, die Seite ändert sich sozusagen nach dem Betrachten. Und im Index von Google steht halt das eine, und auf der Seite steht halt das andere. Das ist eben sehr häufig der Fall.
Ja, aber bei Hardware schaut er genau dasselbe. Also da haben wir doch ein bisschen am Sinn der Sache gezweifelt. Aber danach hatten wir dann ein interessantes Gespräch, weil wir haben immer ein Streitgespräch, und das kommt so ein bisschen mehr auf die höhere Ebene. Aber ihr hattet vorhin mal was gesagt zu dieser Überleitung von Printmedien und von Fehlern, die man dann quasi auch auf der Ebene des Internets, also auch durch diese ganze Werbebranche und so, die sich dann wieder reproduzieren, wobei ich das nicht als Entschuldigung gelten lasse. Man sagt, der Buchdruck hat ja viel Zeit gehabt, da seine Fehler zu machen und zu berichtigen. Und da hatten wir irgendwie das Gespräch. Es ist immer so ein Streitgespräch. Ich sag ihm halt immer, eigentlich werf ich ihm vor, dass sein Job eigentlich ein bisschen ideologisch ist. Und er sagt mir eigentlich immer, dass ich eigentlich mehr ein Fachidiot bin, in technischer Hinsicht.
Was war jetzt nochmal sein Job genau?
Kommunikationswissenschaft hat er studiert und dann hat er noch umgeschult auf Content Manager. Hat aber von der Hardware weniger Ahnung. Gut, und ich sag ihm dann, er sagt halt, Ideologie ist, was die Sowjetunion gemacht hat oder die Nazis. Wenn ich ihm sage, Hollywood war auch Ideologie und im Endeffekt Werbebranche ist auch Ideologie. Also da fangen immer unsere Streitgespräche an.
Die Diskussion kenne ich sehr gut, ist halt immer das gleiche. Ich sag halt, Flash ist scheiße und der andere ist aber toll und du verstehst ja überhaupt gar nicht die Psychologie dahinter. Dann sag ich, du bist aber nicht in der Suchtmaschine. Dann kann man halt lange darüber diskutieren. Tatsache ist er nicht in der Suchtmaschine.
Ja, jedenfalls, was der interessante Punkt war, war, dass ich einfach gesagt habe, es ging eigentlich um den Hype. Und dass man sagt, da haben Leute in der Branche, in der New Economy, haben daran gearbeitet, haben mit vielen Worten um sich geworfen, haben auch irgendwo sehr viele Banken oder Investoren gefunden. Dann kam irgendwie erst mal nicht viel Handfestes raus. Nicht viel, was wirklich eine Idee war. Und auch nicht wirklich viel, womit man dann wirklich auch mal einen Mark-Umsatz gemacht hat. Und dasselbe ist dann passiert. Dann haben Leute Magazine, die dann schnell wieder sterben, rausgebracht. Und die sind quasi diesem Hype, den sie selber mitgemacht haben, auch erlegen. Das heißt, sie haben dann halt, meinetwegen, Wiener Tempo war ja in den 80er Jahren schon so ein Anfang. Also hat man dann für diese Leute, die von diesem Hype leben, hat man dann Rolex-Uren oder der schickste Auto oder den schickste Brausekopf oder sonst was angeboten. Und irgendwann hat man sich gewundert, dass man pleite geht, weil man zum Beispiel nicht kapiert hat, dass diese Leute, die diese Statussymbole kaufen, eigentlich auch gar kein Geld mehr haben oder selber pleite sind. Bloß weil, wenn ich eine Zeitung mache und will die verkaufen, dann muss ich so ein bisschen über der Sache stehen. Und die Leute sind also eigentlich, die sich diese Kleider machen, sind sie so ein bisschen erlegen.
Richtig, sie haben nur einen Teil mitbekommen, dessen was da draußen tatsächlich läuft. Sie sind drauf reingefallen.
Ja, und haben sich aber selber auf ihr Design, ihrer Zeitung oder meinetwegen ihre Webseite kapriziert. Und haben eigentlich gar nicht mehr drauf geachtet, was der Inhalt ist oder ob den überhaupt noch einer gebrauchen kann.
Absolut richtig, die Straße folgte auf den Fuß, so heißt es doch.
Ja, und so ist das bei Webseiten aber auch. Aber man kann halt Leuten, zum Beispiel wieder in einer Metzgerei, kann man viel erzählen. Aber ich würde das nicht in der Metzgerei vorwerfen, sondern ich würde eigentlich sagen, wer macht diese Internetseiten? Was ist das für eine Werbeagentur?
Ja, der Fleischerei habe ich das auch nicht vorgeworfen. Ich habe nur zur Kenntnis genommen, dass die Eröffnungsseiten nicht drauf standen.
Darüber hatten wir uns vorhin auseinandergesetzt. Ich bin ja dann auch deine Meinung, dass ich sage, es sind die Werbeagenturen, die das den Fleischereien und nicht nur denen verkaufen.
Schuld ist immer das Marketing.
Ja, aber die Versucheneime halt, also sagen wir mal so, ich gehe auch nicht hin. Also ich kenne keinen Menschen. Ich freue mich über eine lustige Werbung, aber ich kaufe eigentlich nie einen Artikel, weil die Werbung toll ist. Ich kenne eigentlich auch niemand, der das macht. Ich kaufe mir das einmal und wenn es mir nicht schmeckt, dann kaufe ich es mir nie wieder. Ich kann mich über die Werbung trotzdem amüsieren, aber ich finde, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem von dieser ganzen Kommerzialisierung.
Es gibt ja Statistiken, die überlegen, dass Werbung die interessante ist, wo die Leute sagen, das ist eine tolle Werbung, zum Beispiel Camel oder so, dass diese Werbung in der Regel nie gezogen hat, also dass die nicht viel verkauft haben, diese klassische voll in die Fresse Werbung, dieses kauftest du dumme Sau, das kaufen die Leute merkwürdigerweise. Das ist genauso wie Ich bin noch nicht blöd von Media Markt oder Geiz ist geil oder so. Das sind halt die ganz dummen Sachen, aber die rufen das tatsächlich an.
Ja und ich sehe halt im Internet das so, dass es im Moment schon ein heilsamer Prozess ist, dass man da sagt, also dieser ganze Müll und diese Nullinformation, die sich aber da unheimlich ausbreitet und die alles kommerzialisiert, ich finde das gut, was ihr so gesagt habt, dass sich da irgendwie auch neue Strukturen entwickeln.
Das ist richtig, es gehört beides dazu. Es ist die Information und es ist die Verpackung von der Information. Beides dient dazu, eine Information von mir zu dir zu übertragen.
Manchmal, je bunter die Verpackung, desto weniger Information. Also jemand, der alte Omas an der Haustür belemmern will, da zieht sich ja auch ein schicke Klamotten an. Und jetzt habe ich noch eine Frage an euch. Und zwar weil ich jetzt so geduldig gewartet habe, ich habe auch eine ganz kurze Frage. Und zwar, ich wollte schon mal irgendwann euer Radio anrufen, bin aber nie durchgekommen. Ich habe mal eine Frage. Ich habe ein ganz altes Handy. 3-4 Jahre alt, ein prepaid Handy. Wenn ich das einschalte und will in meinen Adressbruch reingehen, dann dauert das jedes Mal eine Minute. Er sagt, bitte warten, bitte warten. Das habe ich mal einen schrecklichen Verdacht. Liegt das daran, weil das Handy mein Telefonbuch erstmal in seinem Betriebssystem so lange laden muss? Oder ist das in Wirklichkeit so, dass dieser Schweineprovider wirklich mein gesamtes Telefonnummernverzeichnis bei sich auf dem Server hat und das erst übers Netz aufs Handy geraten wird? Weil das Handy eigentlich schon ein Skandal, ne?
Nein, es ist nicht so.
Es ist nicht so, bin ich aber ruhig.
Dein Handy ist einfach langsam.
Uwe, viel Spaß noch mit dem Ding. Ansonsten weiterhin klick mich an.
Wenn Fritz rundum bälzig, dann 91, 9.
Es ist natürlich in den letzten Minuten signifikant kälter geworden. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen minus zwei und minus sieben Grad. Am Tag ist es meist, ich sag bewusst meist, nur locker bewölkt. Und es bleibt trocken. Die Temperaturen steigen auf sechs bis zehn Grad. Jetzt aber rascher Mente. Die Meldung mit Bastien Boehner.
Russland und Deutschland fordern weiter eine friedliche Entwaffnung des Irak. Das ist das Ergebnis des Gesprächs zwischen Bundeskanzler Schröder und dem russischen Präsidenten Putin. Beide sind dafür, die Waffenkontrollen im Irak fortzusetzen. Im britischen Parlament haben sich zahlreiche Abgeordnete der Regierungspartei gegen einen Irakkrieg ausgesprochen. Medien sprechen von mehr als 100 Kriegsgegnern aus den Reihen der Labour Party von Premierminister Blair. Die Parlamentsmehrheit unterstützt allerdings den Kurs von Blair, darunter auch die konservative Opposition. Bahnkunden müssen ab Samstag mit bundesweiten Warnstreiks rechnen. Heute waren die Tarifverhandlungen ohne Ergebnis vertagt worden. Die Gewerkschaft will nun mit Warnstreiksdruck auf die Geschäftsleitung der Bahn ausüben. Und zum Sport in der Fußball Champions League verlor Bayerler Leverkusen bei Newcastle United mit 1 zu 3. Leverkusen bleibt damit in der Vorrunde ohne jeden Punkt gewinnen. Ja und der Verkehr auf Ritz hat keine Meldungen, deswegen meiern wir um Brum.
Bestimmen sie mit und wähl deine Lieblingssongs.
Änderungsvorschläge.
20 plus 1, die Fritz Hörer-Charts. Jeden Sonntag von 12 bis 14 Uhr. Und im Radio.
Ja, jetzt wo du geschmatzt hast, haben wir noch nicht viele Leute angerufen, spontan im Chaosradio auf Ritz. Wir sind natürlich immer noch zu dritt, Tim, Arne und meine Person Max und Gregor, der im Hintergrund auch weiterhin Platten auflegen wird. Am Telefon ist oder müsste eigentlich erst mal sein, das Freizeichen auf der einen Seite, das muss man auch immer mal wieder vorspielen.
Ja hallo.
Ja, ich habe die Frage, wir machen gerade als Schulprojekt ein PHP-Shop, also halt ein Shopsystem, was man, dass wir einen PHP prämieren, was halt über eine Datenbank läuft und wo wir halt verschiedene in der Schule gefertigte Sachen halt verkaufen. Und da ist die Frage, wie kann ich den Inhalt aus der Datenbank für die Suchmaschinen sichtbar machen oder ist das überhaupt möglich? Oder wie macht das Amazon oder so?
Na ja, Amazon macht das nicht anders als andere Webseiten auch. Zunächst einmal solltest du vor allem darauf achten, dass das HTML, was du ausspruchst, möglichst einem der Standards genügt. Also HTML4 oder vielleicht auch schon XHTML1, was im Prinzip dasselbe ist, auch wenn sie es ein bisschen anders schreibt. Damit machst du es den Suchmaschinen schon mal sehr einfach. Das zweite, also ich meine, wenn es dir sozusagen um den Inhalt geht, hast du natürlich vor allem dann viel Erfolg, wenn deine Webseite sehr konsistent rüberkommt. Das heißt, wenn du zum Beispiel den Titel klug wählst und wenn du auch darauf achtest, dass das, was im Titel angekündigt wird, auch vom Inhalt, also allein vom Lesen her, vom Satzbau her, auch so auf der Webseite vorzufinden. Solche Zusammenhänge werden zum Beispiel in Suchmaschinen geprüft.
Mein Problem ist, dass die Information, die hier durchsucht werden soll, sich nicht irgendwo als HTML-Seite befindet und auch nicht als CFD-Seite, sondern in der Datenbank liegt.
Ja gut, aber du hast ja Links, den man folgen kann. Genau das macht ja Google, genauso wie ich auf deiner Webseite rumklicke.
Auf die Datenbank-Sachen durch.
Das sollten sie tun. Das hängt so ein bisschen von den URLs ab. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, was Google ausschließt. Hier fehlt noch ein Mikrofon.
Du müsstest da den Linken... Hast du angenommen?
Hab ich. Ja, Google ist es relativ egal, ob das aus einer Datenbank kommt oder ob das aus einer statischen Datei kommt. Die Frage ist, was ist tatsächlich da? Und du sagst, da sind Informationen, die sind in der Datenbank, aber dann nicht auf der Seite. Dann kann Google die natürlich auch nicht finden.
Also ich habe ja im Prinzip nicht eine Seite, die ich jetzt direkt programmiere, sondern ich zu einem PfD-System programmieren.
Und das greift auf eine Datenbank zu.
Genau und wenn man dann halt eingibt, ich will gerne den Artikel der Kategorie so haben, dann tut er halt auf die Datenbank zugreifen und spuckt die alle aus.
Dann solltest du es einfach so gestalten, dass du eben nicht nur auf eine Eingabe hin überhaupt erstmal was ausspuckst, sondern dass du auch eine Übersicht hast über wie viele Artikel es sich denn hier handelt.
Ja, um nicht so viele.
Na ja, dann sprichst du jetzt dagegen, eine Übersichtseite zu bauen.
Ja oder die ganzen Beschreibungen als Datei direkt zu speichern und nicht in einer Datenbank.
Was du auch tun könntest, und das wäre sozusagen ganz aktuell hier unser Thema, könnte es auch überlegen, ob du deinen Produktkatalog sozusagen auch zum Beispiel im RDF-Format mit auf die Webseite packst. RDF ist dieses Resource Description Framework, das in einigen Fällen also klingt kompliziert, ist aber immer wieder ganz einfach, weil sonst wäre es kein Webstandard. Das ist so eine Möglichkeit, um den Inhalt der Webseite sozusagen nach außen hin zu deklarieren. Da muss man sich so ein bisschen rein denken, ist aber nicht wirklich schwierig. Und sowas wird von modernen Suchmaschinen auch durchaus schon berücksichtigt.
Gleich mal in meinem Informatik-Lehrer vorschlagen.
Genau, machen wir www.w3.org. Da gibt es dann links eine ganze Liste von Technologien. HTML ist da nur eine davon und RDF ist eine andere.
Ja und wie gesagt, der Suchmaschine ist es egal, woher die Seiten, woher die Informationen kommen, ob das aus einer Datenbank oder im statischen Files ist, ob das PHP oder Perl ist. Das spielt keine Rolle, aber das kann man sich auch selber angucken, denn du programmierst das und schaust dir dann, was kommt dabei raus und kannst das auch entsprechend bewerten.
Und das macht auch die Suchmaschine.
Ja, alles, was man klicken kann, ohne dass man was eingeben muss. Das ist das, was auch Google sieht.
Und die Suchmaschine sieht nichts anderes als das, was wir aufsehen. Dann gibt es natürlich noch die Informationen, die in der Webseite selber stehen, die aber vom Browser nicht unmittelbar angezeigt werden. Das ist, um gefunden zu werden, noch ein ganz heißes Thema. Das sind nämlich die Metatechs.
Da hat es halt keiner Lust, die ganzen Beschreibungen alle in Metatech zu schreiben.
Ist aber Pflicht, ist Handwerk.
Im Prinzip, wenn du eine überschaubare Liste von Artikeln hast, also wenn du jetzt mal nicht so eine Million hast oder so, wenn es durchaus denkbar wäre, dass du, von was von der Zahl reden wir? 100?
Ja, ungefähr 100.
Aber warum nicht eine Übersicht schaffen, wo im Prinzip auch ein Link zu jedem einzelnen Produkt ist, wo du eine Seite pro Item hast, sozusagen, und wo dann auch die Seite ausschließlich mit Informationen über dieses Ding, was es auch mal sein mag, gefüllt ist. Und wenn das irgendwie erklickbar ist, ohne dass man etwas eingibt, ohne dass man irgendwas sucht, was sowieso zu empfehlen wäre, dann findet das auch die Suchmaschine, und dann kannst du schwer davon ausgehen, dass was man auch immer irgendwie eingibt, dass man das dann auch gleich die passende Seite dazu findet. Dann hat man halt auch gleich auf den ersten Klick die Seite, wo genau das ist und nix anderes.
Ja, dann ist das Problem gelöst. Und ja, den Mediatek könnte ich auch einfach mit PHP generieren, dann wäre das Problem ja auch gelöst. Gut, und dann wollte ich noch was sagen zu eurem Flash-Hass. Und zwar, es kommt drauf an, was man machen will im Web, ob der Flash sinnvoll ist oder auch nicht.
Richtig, das ist die Frage. Was möchtest du machen?
Ja, also wenn ich Informationen haben will, dann will ich keinen Flash. Dann hab ich auch Flash und dann tue ich mich ja sehr drüber ärgern. Aber wenn ich Kunst haben will und Spielzeug haben will und Spiel haben will, dann...
Es gibt natürlich die Flash-Kunst und dafür brauchst du Flash. Und das ist auch nicht verwerflich.
Ja, für Animationen ist es auch ganz prima. Aber es gibt halt viele Leute, die geben sich der Illusion hin. Es gibt so etwas wie eine Flash-Site. Sowas gibt es nicht.
Wenn man einfach ganz einfache Informationen in Flash verpackt, finde ich das schlimm. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn MTV eine Seite hat, oder einen Bereich hat, der sehr wenig Informationen hat, der aber sehr viel Image ausstrahlen soll, wie ja MTV auch die ganzen Zwischenfilme immer hat, die einfach nichts aussagen, die einfach nur Kunst sind eigentlich.
Ja klar, wenn man Sachen hat, die nichts aussagen, dann kann man natürlich machen, was man will. Aber das ist nicht unser Thema. Uns geht es irgendwie um Sachen, die eben was aussagen. Und aussage-lose Sachen braucht man eh nicht zu kommentieren. Ich meine, wenn die das für eine wichtige Sache halten, sich darzustellen und zu sein, und mit diesem etwas schwammigen Image-Dingsbums zu arbeiten, das ist halt das, was so Marketing-Leute machen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob du dich schon mal mit Marketing-Leuten unterhalten hast, das macht eigentlich keinen Spaß.
Ich mache halt Web-Design und klar, es gibt halt wirklich oft Fälle, wo halt irgendjemand einfach sagt, ja ich will Flash-Leute haben, weil das lustig blinkt. Und da sage ich dann auch, ja vielleicht ist HTML eine beste Lösung. Aber es gibt halt auch Fälle, also sobald es halt irgendwie mit Kunst zu tun hat, ist einfach, finde ich, der Rahmen, den HTML hat, sehr eng. Und in Flash gibt es einfach wirklich unbegrenzte Möglichkeiten.
Ich finde ehrlich gesagt die Möglichkeiten in Flash sehr begrenzt. Also ich meine allein schon, dass man, das Problem ist, Flash ist ein Programm. Das heißt, wenn man mit Flash arbeitet, arbeitet man mit einem Programm. Und du kannst diese Zustände, die du da klicken kannst, die ja teilweise auch interessante Informationen unter Umständen bieten, die kannst du halt nicht bookmarken, da kannst du nicht drauf linken. Du kannst damit gar nichts machen, du kannst es noch nicht mal drucken. Und das ist irgendwie sinnlos. Wenn man jetzt der Meinung ist, man müsste halt was Sinnloses in seiner Webseite haben, dann soll man es reintun. Einetwegen, das ist mir egal.
Ja, also ob es sinnlos ist oder nicht, dann hat man auf jeden Fall nicht den einfachen Informationssinn. Es hat halt einen anderen Sinn. Aber das glaube ich einfach geschmacksam. Ihr habt einfach dazu nicht so den Bezug, aber ich bin halt so in Kreisen unterwegs, wo viele nur in Flash leben.
Oh, ich kenne diese Kreise besser als du vielleicht glaubst, aber das erinnert kein Stück an meiner Überzeugung.
Aber ist es doch mal im Ernst, ist es nicht einfach und sowieso Pflicht zu sagen, ich setze eine HTML-Seite vor, diese ganze Flash-Seite, frage ob derjenige oder diejenige überhaupt Flash haben möchte jetzt an dieser Stelle und die HTML-Seite an sich kann in ihren Metatext sowieso die ganze Kacke eingebaut haben, die in diese restlichen Seiten auch kommen? Ja, ich frag euch, weil es muss so sofort anstehen.
Man schließt auch Leute aus durch Flash. Flash ist ein Produkt von der Firma Macromedia, das ist kein Web-Standard. Das ist ganz einfach.
Ja, was ich öfters mache, ist, dass ich eine HTML-Version mache, die auch für alle geht, oder unten eine Flash-Version mache, die für die geht, die nichts gegen Flash haben. Aber das ist teilweise einfach übertrieben viel Arbeit und sinnlos.
Julius, vielen Dank! Na gut, gute Nacht noch. Wir wollen eben noch den Matthias dran nehmen. Hallo Matthias. Hallöchen. Dass du zum Abschluss deiner Frage schon noch stellen kannst, weil die Zeit ist fast rum im Chaos Radio hier auf Fritz und gleich kommt Martin Peters auf dem Live-Shot. Wir haben noch ein paar Minuten.
Ja, ja, das sehe ich ja schon. Sorry. Also, ähm, für die Suchmaschinen mit den Framesets. Ja, du hast vorhin gesagt irgendwie, dass, nee, ich hab da nicht gesagt, aber, ähm, Suchmaschinen halt gehört, dass die irgendwie Probleme haben damit, irgendwie die Seiten zu finden, wenn sie Frames haben. Irgendwie. Dass nicht eine komplette HTML-Seite ist, sondern, ähm, dann war es zwei Frames, die unterteilt sind.
Ja, naja, Suchmaschinen finden das schon, weil es ist ja natürlich verlinkt. Äh, finden ist gar nicht so das Problem. Also, viele Seiten, die Frames verwenden, wenn du da irgendwie die in den Suchergebnissen hast, dann findest du so häufig die Beschreibungen, diese Webseite unterstützt keine, ihr Webbrowser unterstützt keine Frames, ihr Webbrowser unterstützt keine Frames, ihr Webbrowser unterstützt keine Frames, das ist schonmal so die Beschreibung, die man dann sozusagen zum gefundenen Inhalt findet. Der Grund ist, dass sozusagen eine andere Seite indiziert wird als die, die sozusagen die eigentliche Information trägt, weil ein Webbrowser zeigt es anders an, als Google es indiziert. Das ist aber, sagen wir mal, eher noch das geringere Problem, weil natürlich haben die sich bei den Suchmaschinen, die Programmierer haben sich schon Mühe gegeben, auch das zu finden, was man mit dem Webbrowser sieht. Also von der Suchmaschine her ist es nicht das Thema. Es ist aber sehr anstrengend, wenn du es selber benutzt, wenn du selber im Web searchst und du hast jetzt eine Webseite, die aus 5-6 Frames besteht, oder lass es nur 2 sein, oder lass es eigentlich nur 1 sein, und dann ist da oben noch so ein Pseudoframe, der irgendwie gar nicht sichtbar ist, nur weil der Webseitenprogrammierer der Meinung war, es wäre jetzt eine tolle Idee, dass egal wie man da rumklickt, oben immer die gleiche Webadresse drinsteht. Auch sowas gibt es ja. Und das Problem ist, wie soll ich bitte da von einem Bookmark machen? Also wie soll ich mir die Stelle merken, an der ich gerade arbeite? Wie soll ich die jemand anders schicken? Klar, ich weiß, das ist ein Frame, und dann sag ich irgendwie Show this Frame oder Copy Link of this Frame, aber es macht die Sache einfach unnötig kompliziert. Und vor allem, wenn ich dann jemanden irgendwie den Link von diesem Frame schicke und er macht den dann auf, dann gibt es halt irgendwie zwei verschiedene Sachen. Erstens, man sieht halt nur den Frame, aber nicht mehr die ganze Navigation dazu. Das heißt, du kriegst sozusagen nur die Hälfte der Information mit. Und dann gibt es dann aber noch so die Kandidaten, die dann noch speziellen JavaScript-Code in diese Seite reinbauen, die dann irgendwie einen Reload machen, womit du sogar verhinderst, dass man sich nur den Frame anschauen kann. Was auch noch ein echtes Problem ist mit Frames, ist, du kannst sie im Prinzip nicht wirklich drucken. Du kannst sie nämlich nur dann drucken, wenn sie auch wirklich in deinem Formatierungsbereich komplett der Inhalt drauf passt. Aber angenommen, du hast zwei Frames übereinander und beide sind im Prinzip drei Seiten lang. Was willst du da drucken? Du machst irgendwie APFEL-P, du kriegst irgendwie so einen Teil davon ausgedruckt, aber nicht das, was dich wirklich interessiert.
Das ist immer eine Abwägung der Mittel und es gibt keinen Grund, der für Frames spricht. Alles ist auch in HTML ohne Frames möglich. Das ist meine Erfahrung. Wirklich alles.
Bei mir gibt es ja bloß mit dem Frame-Halte-Thema oben habe ich so einen Dummy-Frame eingebaut, der eine Höhe Null hat. Dabei waren halt wirklich nur meine Original-URLs.
Ja, aber warum soll man das? Die Leute wollen doch linken. Lass sie doch linken. Lass sie doch im Prinzip nicht mehr von besser finden.
Das ist ja nicht so ein Problem wieder zu ändern. So große Unterschied ist es nicht, wenn man nur den Game-Frame hat.
Es zählt die, die dir am Schluss nur Ärger macht.
Ja, bei mir gibt es doch ein bisschen um das Aussehen so.
Aber das weißt du doch eh nicht, wie der Browser das anzeigt. Manche Leute zeigen ja noch nicht mal oben die Adresse an.
Mein Tiers, da wir jetzt zum Ende der Sendung kommen müssen, leider Gottes, da uns die Zeit davon läuft, will ich mich herzlich bei dir bedanken und du hast ja nun das Manifest das Kleine noch gehört, was Tim hier am Ende abgelassen hat. Warum Frames so scheiße sind, da haben wir ihn echt angestochen. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ja, zusammengefasst, wenn ihr nochmal Bock habt, Feedback loszuwerden, es gibt die Möglichkeit, das jetzt, weil die Sendung telefonisch zu Ende gegangen ist, per Mail zu tun, 79, weil das nicht um die 79.
Sendung handelt, at. Im Studio waren, vielleicht verabschieden wir uns einfach alle nochmal selber. Der Arne. Ja, besten Dank, hat Spaß gemacht. Tatsächlich. Tim sagt auch Tschüss, versucht schon wieder, links seinen Powerbook zu entstöpseln. Das heißt, wir rüsten jetzt hier ab und spielen für die letzten zwei Minuten, zumindest noch, bevor Martin Petersdorf sich mit dem Night Flight meldet, hier auf Fritz. Musik von Gregor, der tapfer durchgehalten hat mit dem DJ-Set, das wir zum Teil nur im Hintergrund hören konnten, aber das hat wenigstens die richtige Stimmung gegeben. Danke auch dafür. Mein Name ist Max von Malotki, ich sage Tschüss.